two
welcome everybody to the hard-hitting
journalistic uh
funny
relevant important
transcending podcasts in the world
we're not just doing Goose here it's
actually so much more
and that's the H3 podcast welcome to it
thank you guys for being here thank you
to our sponsor expressvpn who we love
oh yes it's all for the rails you know
what that means
[Music]
[Applause]
wow wow
you know we are the world
and I always say that and thank you to a
Nook who any progress on that Zach uh
getting a Nook you're the one that
reached out to him right
I believe that may have been Olivia
um yeah she's downstairs helping with
the photo shoot right now okay yeah
how's everybody doing today
great good you know I actually did
something yesterday I met my friend at
Topgolf have you guys been there I know
of it I've never been to one it's like a
driving range right it's crazy it's like
a
it's like a massive three-story driving
range and you can eat and drink there
they serve you yeah but then they've got
this crazy Tech where they can track the
ball
show you your exact shot nice
I don't know how they do that
I just hit my balls but it it's great
it's really crazy it's like super
futuristic there
um
so I actually did something yesterday
which felt weird that's crazy yourself
do you have fun yes I did thank you for
asking
the fact that you went out and hung out
with somebody is crazier than the bulk
technology yeah he's my buddy from
college I mean we're we're friends he's
one of my few like actual like you know
friends
so sad it's not that sad it's not that
sad I have friends
[Music]
but you know it's funny because I
haven't really gone out in a while
especially by myself so I walk in there
and it's just so weird it's a little
weird the place as it is like
because everything's automated there
there's no like reception
you check in with your phone and I
didn't know any of this so I'm like
what do I do I go up to the second one I
see everyone's golfing but there's no
there's no one to talk to there's no
information wow
so I had to pull down one of the waiters
who knew who I was
I said how do I do this that's what I
asked him
he said go downstairs uh there's a
little desk there
went downstairs to the desk
they said what's your phone number
Lena made the reservation for me so I
says can I give you a different phone
number they said no you cannot you know
I need that original phone or I said
really
you're like we need to check you and I
said I'm here here I am it's me
do I get Lena's phone number they send
Lena a message to confirm
you know and then I had wanted to add my
buddy to the account well guess what
they had to send him a text too it's me
to add him to the game
you know what I mean this is why you
never go out
that's the game you know and So
eventually we get up I think the reason
they make you sign in with your phone is
because you need to sign a uh like a
liability release because it's [__]
dangerous there people are drinking
hitting balls all crazy you know
sometimes you hit a golf ball and it
goes like
it goes like parallel to you somehow
like you're hitting it out but it goes
totally sideways right
that's scary and the people around there
like nobody there really knows how to
golf and there's dudes who are just like
they're hitting it like it's all on the
line
and it's just out it's just flagrant and
outrageous and everybody's drunk feels
dangerous and then we drank beer right
at the edge because you're really high
up there's three stores we're on the
Second Story
The Edge is just a full-on drop down oh
there's like a little net right
and then a full on drop down to the
driving green with a bunch of drunk
Rowdy people and so yeah I was thinking
man this someone probably falls into
that net every day
Topgolf injury that's what I'm saying
someone I bet someone's died there no no
joke
lawsuits against Topgolf for preventable
injuries
um and it's not a lie so Top Golf facing
lawsuits after widespread injuries to
customers that's awesome
and it's not a lot like here you can see
so it's like all these stalls it's
almost like a bowling alley in the way
that they that's set it up that's how
it's been described to me yeah
and it is very fun like the fun I don't
want to go do it yeah
the concept is great and actually the
execution is great
but it's like one of those things like
that
we can't have good we can't have nice
things anymore right oh [__] AB just
shared something me
is this okay to show yeah he didn't get
like seriously injured here no he's he's
chilling oh wait I want to see this I've
been Dynasty so here's someone falling
off but here you guys can see if you
show this picture it's a small net it's
not a big net yeah you know got them
them Foxconn and people are trashed
trashed
and Swinging hard bro like these guys
think that they will never get laid
again if they don't hit that ball as
hard as they can and they're right
they're right about that well they're
usually just hitting the ground really
hard and missing the ball completely
here's a video of someone dropping in
this is awesome
this is awesome it's a trip he took to
Topgolf oh okay so check out what
happened after he took a big swing from
the upper deck man tried to focus on the
ball but completely misses it right here
that didn't stop him in celebrating as
if he did hit the ball and then pointing
in the distance there it goes he takes
one too many steps
and get into the network the networks
the network that looked like a heavier
also still smiling still smiling having
a great time he's drunk as [__] that man
literally just walked right off the edge
but that's it that's the vibe it's kind
of cool all right
so you're going to be a top golf guy now
I'll go back there yeah your membership
I'll go back there I love Topgolf we're
Topgolf fans oh you guys do it
one of our like First Dates was at
Topgolf that's a good date spot it is
it's like the the bowling alley people
think is a good day spot it's way too
loud there Topgolf
you can talk oh interesting it's not
super loud yeah mine and woman of mine
Alina's First Dates was at a bowling
alley and it was so [__] awkward I
don't know why yeah probably you're
right probably is too loud it's a
horrible first date you'd think it would
be good but it's actually one of the
worst first day at locations yeah
[__] loud so your first date was
wasn't good with Lena I mean it was
sweet but just like it was we both
sucked at golf so it's just gutter ball
we're gonna hear each other wait did you
say bowling or Topgolf you mean you mean
bowling when I say golf yeah bowling
yeah the different things actually yeah
right
Lena what what is your memory of it
yeah just that we both sucked at it and
then we got ice cream after but it was
nice it wasn't I don't remember it being
like super awkward a b says it was
devastating you didn't see it though did
you feel like you were blowing it baby
uh yeah sort of I felt a little awkward
because for so long I didn't really like
go out for dates like every time I hung
out with the girls kind of we're just
like chilling at the house or something
so it was it was weird Donkey Kong Bongo
and chill yep
it was around that time shortly after
the rest is history yeah
I think it'd be fun as a company event
if we all go to Topgolf just kidding
yeah a drink that's great the only thing
is the only one that's close to us is
kind of far away that's why I haven't
gone because somebody suggested I go and
I saw I was with traffic and it'd be
like 40 minutes or something 40 minutes
with traffic actually was only 20
minutes we went at nine o'clock it was
only 20 minute drive but it's like a
little too far to Uber right so then
here's another thing you want to drink
so yeah here's another thing
you look at this parking lot Parker
there is a lot of cars there
everybody there is drinking
it's in the middle of nowhere
I'm not understanding the math here yeah
yeah that does sound questionable who
the [__] there's just Mass drunk driving
going on at Topgolf
it's in uh
what's that place called oh look it up
it is funny by the way right I'm drunk
oh my God it's windy the hell building's
about to collapse Alfredo's scared
it's okay alfredo El Segundo El Segundo
baby
how the [__] are you not drunk but look
at it but look at this it looks so
futuristic
can see it from like a mile away you
know what it looks like it looks like
the [__] dude perfect uh oh true
the Dude Perfect compound sorry the dogs
are scared from the wind they're inspo
so anyway that was it so yeah let's go
let's go uh drink responsibly at Topgolf
thank you thank you to everybody yeah
so there's been a little bit of drama
drama
as the Australians say
drummer
first of all our thumbnail
comes to courtesy of
Joe Bagan read it vegan
uh
I'm not sure either Biden baijin
yes John isn't John here
came up with a banger uh thumbnail you
know what's funny this might sound
facetious to you but
I learned yesterday after looking more
into this uh Marx claims that he can
overcome Tourette's he's very careful
not to say cure right but he now says he
can do it in four hours which is kind of
on the Mr Beast level of fixing the eyes
right have a good night
thank you thank you
God so so that was exciting
here's some great memes of uh
the aftermath here it is
it was quite a big moment I think for
the show I I felt that it was a nice
moment
here is another one bites the dust
here's Carlos before and after
here's Crowder before and after oh no
and car and uh Mark before and after
yeah I do I have that effect on people
you know what I'm starting to think
Bobby Lee was right about you you're the
gotcha guy is that what he said about
you he did say I'm the gotcha guy but
I'm not the gotcha guy no I've been a
gotcha guy gotcha clearly but I didn't
feel like I was I guess with him maybe
it was a gotcha but it was never my
intention yeah
I think with all is it really a gotcha
you're here talking about yourself no I
think you just slam dunk in these
moments yeah it's not really aggressive
it's impressive to watch Jeff was a
gotcha that was the one time with Jeff
whittick with the picture that was a
gotcha gotcha got your hat I was a
gotcha
yeah
um Mark responded on Twitter
by the way I talked a lot about this and
did some real interesting background
research yesterday on see you next
Tuesday the with that our podcast for
members and it was fun it actually
derailed when when uh podcast with Ethan
Philip DeFranco accused me of fat
shaming him
which I'll talk about
after this
but
Ethan making people's day I mean yes if
you do it backwards this is how we see
you look you know what this is really
nice
I love this this is so nice look how
happy they are in the end
I love dogs that's wholesome that is
awesome
yeah unfortunately and it's not real
uh Mark Elliott
he is in damage control he says yes I
fell into a trap going on the H3 podcast
it was not really a trap it's like he
walked into the ocean
he slowly walked in here yeah it came
out he's not really there was no trap
yeah like we well I mean he doesn't yeah
he trapped himself he walked into our he
walked in we never misled him at all
he walked in and we said yes come on the
show
yeah at the beginning of the interview
you misled him by saying like you were a
supporter or whatever
um but that that was after he was
already here he had every opportunity to
know beforehand what what he was signing
up never ever
yeah and none of none of our
communication prior to the show did we
give any indication that we believed a
word that he was saying I'm actually
really proud of how we handled the
communication yeah because I do think it
was important that we
did not
uh deceive him at all
and we did it
so he said yes I fell into a trap going
on the History Podcast thanks for the
tag
at the end though Ethan was afraid to
play the video of digital forensic
experts talking about the evidence
tampering in the U.S first for Neary as
it might be too compelling he ended up
playing it but couldn't resist mocking
it so here he is talking about how he
actually had the dub
so last night I went on the H3 podcast
with Ethan Klein and boy did I walk into
the Trap Of My Life Ethan called me out
at the beginning he said you did not do
your research and no Ethan I did not do
enough research about Ethan Klein sir so
you definitely got me there okay
all right let's wrap it up fair enough I
don't think we need to watch anymore
wait he's about to maneuver the whole
thing they were basically playing me you
know he was pretending to agree with me
about this these egregious you know
crimes that that uh the the government
committed in the case of U.S versus
Ranieri when in the in the in the end it
didn't seem that he agreed with my
position with anything you know they
mocked me they had hominin attacks all
this ad hominem I didn't do that did I
let's ad hominem was when I came instead
of his argument yeah I didn't do that
I've never heard that phrase I never
insulted him I feel like everyone on
that side that is one of their favorite
favorite fresh and fair at home that
every argument fresh and fit yeah I feel
like I feel like we were very very on
point with our argument key
argue yeah we were engaging fully is it
ad hominem is that it yeah ad hominem
Pro Hawk ad hominem
well I don't know what prohawk is I just
know it's another fallacy
attacking the person this fallacy occurs
when instead of addressing someone's
argument position you irrelevantly
attack the person or some aspects of the
person who's making the argument for
example would be someone saying I'm fat
and my wife is ugly instead of
addressing the fact that I of what I
said about correct yeah yeah that's a
great example yeah
I'm on the receiving of it end of it all
the time actually in fact
this sort of stuff even at one point
they were claiming that I was making up
my you know living with Tourette's for
20 years it was incredible but despite
you know the craziness of the whole
thing
what was amazing is that at the end I
asked Ethan to play the YouTube video
showing the digital forensic experts
talking about how the government uh
tampered with evidence in the case of
U.S versus Ranieri and even with all the
disagreements we had on that call the
one thing he agreed with is that he was
afraid to play it because he thought it
was too compelling
I think you said it was boring
too boring well that I did said both
yeah no I think you did say that at some
point I was jokingly he said why won't
you play it do you have the this man
really that [__] dense bro no no he
uh is he being he's doing what of course
he's doing he's twisting it and you know
putting his spin on it but it's not I've
been like okay hold on yeah where's the
time stamp where that occurred
uh uh it would be right near the end oh
my God bro that's crazy I mean we were
excited to pull it up because it's
really [__] funny that Alan
dershowitz isn't it so that's not really
true though we didn't want to show it at
all also one of the guys in it is like
at the FBI guys like an election fraud
freak who's
was it all in like Dominion voting yeah
I mean that that was my assumption too
is like whenever you hear that kind of
thing there's a bunch of weirdos I
watched the whole video prior uh when I
was doing the research on it and yeah my
my impression was well first of all a
lot of the people in the video their
statements are kind of like phrased in
such a way that it's kind of vague
almost as if they're responding to a
hypothetical that's what I noticed when
we were watching it they were speaking
like totally yeah no I I think specific
I think I I suspect it was po the
question was posed in such a way
like if the FBI were to have found to
have falsified this metadata or whatever
would that be an egregious you know
infraction on his civil rights and
they're like yeah if that yeah that
would be a huge infraction and then boom
that's your sound bite right there
look how old and weird they all are
like a collection just old weird people
a bunch of pedded offenders
all right so listen we put poor um
Mark through the ringer
and I do feel like after everything
we've been through I do owe it to him to
at least play this video
so he can at least not accuse me of uh
being thinking that it's too compelling
or something
so here it is guys I'm just going to
play it it's only two minutes long
and uh let's just listen to what they
have to say
[Music]
experts versus Keith rainieri I worked
in the FBI for about 10 years it is
clear that the photos in this case were
planted there so this is the most
serious tampering of evidence that I've
ever seen it's inescapable that the FBI
proactively created fake evidence
[Music]
okay okay
Christmas
videos
[Music]
but he was a United States Attorney
anything
he does have this he's compelling yeah
[Music]
okay so so there yeah
to me
[Music]
thank you
um
[Music]
so mark
I think that just cured my Tourette's
yeah
Mark we played the whole thing
uninterrupted I will say that there was
some good points some some compelling
stuff so I encourage people to look into
it follow the threads and they'll might
sign up for Nexium
right it's gonna sound pretty good
have a good night so last night I went
on the H3 oh [__] what a weirdo that he
said
I admitted did you find that yeah watch
this time step this is where he says
that I had to admit that it was two
calendars
this isn't it is it before this sorry I
misunderstood with that thumbstamp
two minutes I'd be grateful if you play
that at least an advocate
if you can find the timestamp I'll open
it but
it's going to be a little messy to
search live
but you know um
that was fun
you know have a good night you as well
you know we talked about how he was on
Theo Vons podcast
and um on our members podcast I did
yesterday I was trying to find some
interesting material
I was watching them speak
and this part stuck out to me I thought
this was really interesting
we've been able to replicate with 10
other people with address get into the
program and get better yes wow well we
created a special thing just for people
with Tourette's
and this is the crazy thing so it took
me like a year and a half to get down 90
as I was describing guess how fast it's
been replicated
I would say I hate when they do this bro
he's not your [__] Pony
he makes some guess
he plays along
I don't know take one guess he is you
have to guess but she doesn't want to
guess
nobody likes the nursing game because
it's either too high or too low and then
it takes them oh you idiot you guessed
wrong [__] [__] you rube
yeah you're way off
man you ruined it
they go how much guess how much this
cost I don't know a thousand dollars bro
you ruined it like 200. you are wrong
it's even you know it's rough when it's
something that's impossible as well he
has no idea how stupid I'm gonna know
how how long it took your dumbass to
cure Tourette's well here it is seven
seven one
he's doing a joke bro just please he's
trying to salvage your boring ass don't
make me pull up Subway Surfer
seven days a week
like seven months
yeah I think so four hours oh wow Jesus
man I hate oh wow
people can get rid of using this to get
rid of the rats
no they can't they really
no so he's so funny I love that he's not
buying he's being really amicable this
whole time but even that claim made Theo
vomit he's like what so if you if you
were wondering if this guy's a scam
artist or not
he just said he can cure people's
Tourette's in four hours
kid you not it was probably one that
sounds like something I would say
I'm dead serious
so this so I want to be really clear
it's not saying anybody can get rid of
their Tourette Syndrome people that had
severe Tourette Syndrome that had tried
tons of different things that wanted
that deeply wanted to get rid of it and
end it for this this to me is so obscene
how he's like it only works for people
that want to get rid of it right like
who the [__] wants Tourette's
you didn't really want to get rid of it
it's not happening for you you gotta
want it you know I'm cool walking around
screaming the n-word on buses
it's happening
um one the one piece of information that
didn't come up during the interview that
uh I wish had was one of the victim
impact statements here I'll send it to
you right now
um actually was from a victim that went
through the Tourette's program oh yeah
and described it as being like just
horribly abusive yeah here um oh wait oh
man
you think we'll come back on
email them say hey you want to hop on do
it oh he's not coming back he might he's
desperate for any attention have a good
night
here's what here's one of the
Victim Impact statements when I was told
I was a candidate for participating in
nexum's Tourette study I believe there
was a legitimate medical study and I was
hopeful that this study would help my
Tourette's four hours clearly you did
not want it yeah they didn't want it
that was their problem I have a victim
uh mentality I love [__] shaking my
head so hard that I have headaches
migraines right but I didn't want it
enough
you know I literally giving myself
because I do this [__] with my wrist I'm
literally giving myself carpal tunnel oh
that's that it does suck my [__] uh
my nerves if I pick something up weird
it's like so painful
this is happening that sucks just give
me four hours Mark please bro I want it
in fact there was no medical screening
in advance of participation and I was
given no information about the study or
its risk no one informed me that the
study in fact required me to take ESP
executive that's their that's their
program yeah
intensives I had no clue that I was
going to be required to take extend
expensive intensives that went from 10
a.m to 9 pm
or that that's crazy or that as a result
I would be obligated to clear broffman
is that was that the other guy that's
the the Seagram's uh heiress person I
believe oh
Claire Rothman let me confirm that
yeah that was like heavily featured in
The Vow documentary
I felt like the weight of the world was
on my shoulders because I needed to
overcome my Twitch in order to prove
that this treatment worked I had to urge
I had to resist the urge to tick at all
costs which is exactly what he said it
wasn't
because I was so afraid to tick and mess
up the study which they told me would
also mess up a cure for Tourette's and
potentially other medical conditions
that Nexium wanted to cure
on two occasions while I was in Albany
Nancy and Mark threatened oh we're
talking about Mark now
they threatened to send me home
they each mentioned that if I don't
start acting better and trying harder I
will have wasted thousands of dollars of
Claire's money that she had spent on me
and their medical experiment it was
scary but I couldn't show that because
showing fear means something is wrong
and I need to be fixed
the study these people did did nothing
for me except ruin my self-esteem ruin
my mental health and made me hate myself
it did not cure my threats in any way
but they just didn't want it enough that
can't be you were outward
try harder okay I love to actually Mark
I brought into this uh yeah I didn't I
read through it and somehow my eyes just
skipped right over the fact that that's
Mark yeah Mark's in this yeah this guy's
actually pretty high up I feel like he's
like very high up involved with all
these folks right have a good night have
a good night
oh well what a piece of [__]
damn
himself I really do wish we had that but
okay we have it now
it was
very dense all the stuff we had too
there was just so much
we went through quite an interview
process because we're looking you know
we were looking for very specific people
that you know we thought just met a
bunch of different conditions that
thought you know that they would be a
good candidate for this
for all of those people I would say
seven seven or eight to a three out of
the ten or down 70 wow and the other six
seven are down 90 Plus
wow and what was so neat is is that once
this is so neat
it's real interesting to think after
reading that Victim Impact statement
that
they were just like torturing these
people
yep like scaring them and brainwashing
them that they can't tick or they're
[__] gonna be
buried alive or something I don't know
started happening over the last four
years we had this incredible filmmaker
who uh he goes we got to start filming
this so we started to film it and so
what was so neat is is that you know
stop saying neat bro it's creeping me
out
I would find someone with Tourette's or
someone would tell me about somebody
with Tourette's yeah and we would go
through this whole process to see if
they would be a good candidate and then
once we thought if we had you know a
good candidate a film crew would go out
to their life film their whole life with
Tourette's they would come work with us
in Albany beat their Tourette's and then
we would go back into their life and
film their life without Tourette
Syndrome dude he's full-time in Alby
that was their main headquarters there's
this one point I'm not going to watch
the whole thing but he goes it's like
fat people they have to really want to
lose the weight Tourette is the same way
I says how's that the same it's a
neurological disorder you could sure
it's like saying you could cure autism
If people really want it you could cure
Down syndrome If people really want it
it's like bro they're me they're they're
not it's not fat
it's your [__] brain
yeah free my boys by the way
Mark I'm with you brother free and all
right
free Keith
here's the here's the exact time stamp
of
from the beginning I'm afraid that it's
compelling frankly I don't want no I
will play it I'll play it I'll play it
so these off is so obviously a goof you
can see the fear in your eyes dude
I said it because I know that's what he
was thinking he's like this is so
compelling
that it's gonna change everything two
minutes I'd be grateful if you play that
at least an advocate
okay cool yeah this alleged FBI
malfeasance yeah
it's awesome
um so I guess probably don't watch this
it's two hours
uh but actually Theo Von has since
talked about him being a Nexium scammer
so
he's
yeah this was like five years ago man
2018. so
Jesus Christ
gunt Squad
just trying to get Jesus
very inspiring to have a man who beat
Tourette's and a man who beat down
syndrome in the same room talking
Anything is Possible
I was just curious what people's
reception was this is a great podcast I
never heard a mark before but I started
digging and learning about ESP program
he cited
okay the ESP was run by Keith Rainier
who was arrested for child trafficking
whoops oops
oopsie Dipsy
um
foreign
there's more stuff here
uh we gotta do a break and we have a
call in 10 minutes from a very special
guest
we do yeah
oh [__] that is a special guest
um
by the way I just want to show a few
more things here
uh
here is this is the guy who made the
documentary who was like the main guy
behind the vowel
he says I just watched a genius
thank you Mark
the good Mark that takes one to no one
the good Mark the good Mark Light Side
mark
um ranieri's spokesperson Eduardo
actually responded
um he has agents he's in jail for 120
years but Eduardo is still out here
fighting the good fight
Justice Advocate bringing Justice to FBI
agents crimes in the Nexium case you
can't beat Darkness with Darkness
so your Darkness
or he's light so were you saying this I
don't no no no Rainier is interesting
this is his spokesman God I got it yeah
just a couple of days ago in the
conversation I had with Ron Sullivan
from Harvard we were talking about how
which could be the Harvard
yo okay all right let me know you know
he's trustworthy let me listen let me
listen people have facilitated the
suppression of due process because we
were clapping when the government
cheated on someone we didn't like funny
coincidence yesterday Mark Elliott who
has been vocal against what the FBI did
to Nexium and ketoneeri Mark went on a
podcast it's called H3 I believe and um
they basically mocked him you know they
invited him as a guest and it was all
sorted yes he reached out to us
yeah makes sense why these people hate
Keith and they believe what the media
says they seem to be very hateful
themselves I'm not the media bro we're
very for the record we're very hateful I
mean I own this whole [__] ain't nobody
pulling strings we do hate pedophiles
though which okay that's fair oh don't
be so hateful cab I don't know man stop
being so weird to start this we in the
words of Kanye we need to stop dissing
pedophiles all the time stop witnessing
the Nazis honed in on this it makes me
think on his website
what he stands for deficiency for even
the most hated the canceled the metude
men the accused anti-masters they're not
the most hated people in the world just
for the world watch it I love the
escalation I love like you know
anti-vaxxers the arrested just general
just everyone everyone who's ever been
arrested all of them yep and then Trump
Biden LGBT people
minorities all minorities left Wingers
right Wingers
someone who said the wrong thing someone
who said or wore the wrong thing Keith
Rainier Keith Rainier no no no no insert
who's next it's like y'all are so dumb
you can't even mask
what this is all about
I hate pedophiles I dare you to put that
next to your face Mark put that on the
list there yeah just put eat that on the
list I mean he clearly does stand for
pedophiles if he's running he's
literally standing what's interesting is
he says the most hated and then put like
basically
I think almost everyone in the country
would fall into one of those guys yeah
it totally redeemable uh debatable stuff
but like the one thing that everybody
agrees on is like
child predators and he didn't actually
put that on that which is what Keith
well but Mark's name was on her key's
name was on there so by proxy so here is
a Eduardo and they started doing what I
was discussing with Ron they started
mocking and you know they're seeing
evidence of uh of the FBI cheating
they're seeing the best cyber experts in
the world saying dude there's lit
there's literally no evidence you showed
no evidence it's just a bunch of Talking
Heads being like can you believe how
corrupt the FBI is there's no evidence
what are you guys talking about
show me evidence
all you go is oh the timestamp was [__]
it that metadata was changed okay show
it to me
and also I don't care because he did a
lot of other [__] other than that hard
drive saying it and they're mocking them
cheering at the destruction of the
Republic so to speak so it wasn't for
the Republic to find that that's what's
going on as we hypothesized again I
believe that this is the devil turning
around on us so brave from Mark Elliott
and good job
good job he nailed it
absolutely a good job y'all need better
spokesman man next team is nothing
without Keith you guys need a cult
leader look at the uh replies to see how
uh this message was uh received let's
see Matt gates from wish
this you bro what's wrong with this I
don't know let's see more replies
um oh look another Ranieri hanger on who
needs to be deprogrammed try me
what does that mean what are we trying
the programming it I guess what's your
name Eagles try to do programming you
know that position is better left for
medical professionals he goes what's
your name
bro's trying to recruit and Twitter
replies what's your name
wow he goes I don't divulge your
personal information to Colt members
sorry you just divulged others info
publicly I suspected another anonymous
chicken he's really in the weeds here
your boy Mark got owned don't know why
you'd cover for someone who's obviously
racist racist I don't know why they well
if you believe that he was faking
Tourette's to say the n-word I guess you
could say he's racist yeah I don't know
supposedly he's supported Kanye when he
was being canceled because of course
he's sick he's he's canceled and
therefore he stands default position of
every single person is just now what the
arrested yeah
um so we love them he also tweeted
something out if you want to call in uh
dude Eduardo do you want to call in like
genuinely come in you know who we are
now
it's not a trap
call in Eduardo
call in
I dare you to call in somebody reach out
to Eduardo you can call him right now
it's live I don't know by the time this
comes back around to him we'll probably
be over this whole thing just like Ron
Sullivan explained a few days ago that
podcast H3 clapped at government
corruption and mocked Mark Elliott for
trying to expose it
yep
um what is this we as a people what the
[__] is all this crap
it's also like weird Speedy [__] like
it's all been recorded on the web camera
yeah
well that's what I was saying about that
that compilation they put together it
was all on Zoom but they just made me
wonder if they like
called a lawyer to ask some legal
questions and just recorded it and put
that on 100 yeah
um
yeah so that was all pretty interesting
I was posted in cold watch apparently
this is oh there's I wanted to give a
crossover shout out over at the Nexium
case
they have longed for someone to call out
Mark Elliott's [__] claim that
Tourette's can be cured Renee didn't
discover [__]
it's a well-known uh that shame and
abuse can force people to hide their
traits I didn't know that shame and
abuse well it sounds like that's what
they were doing
but anyway
um based on that victim statement yeah
it sounded like they were like threat
like if you don't
you're ruining everything you're ruining
our lives if you don't cure your
Tourette's
yeah so there it is lots of going on
there
a lot of people were saying maybe this
is why Mark thought
I was Pro Andrew Tate
and he did address his email to Dear H3
podcast highlights
this was his research see why is it so
windy outside bro what the [__] going
on well there's a giant storm blowing
into L.A it's supposed to rain super
you're supposed to potentially snow in
La over the next few days but it sounds
like crazy Grand Theft Auto well I know
all I hear is
the building is like shaking from when
given right it's the biggest trick in
the year yeah whatever you say Kim oh
it's gonna start raining today yeah
okay yeah there's like blizzard warnings
in L.A County right now which really
very unusual yeah
oh [__] okay
so I was wrong about Andrew Tay and then
there's another one here
why I changed my mind Andrew take Lily
did not click the videos but uh that's
so funny click baiting backfired on in
his case
but okay let's get to let me thank the
sponsors and let's get to our very
special caller everyone's Gonna Love yep
we have one sponsor let me quick because
I thank them quickly expressvpn
we love expressvpn thank you so much for
sponsoring us you've heard me talking
about how important it is to have a VPN
to protect your all my privacy but
choosing a VPN you trust
is equally as important now I like to do
research on my sponsors we always do and
I only recommends Brands to my listeners
that I believe in and I actually do
believe in expressvpn we've been working
with them for a while
only positive things
uh and all the years we've been working
with them number one expressvpn doesn't
log your activity online lots of cheap
or free vpns make money by selling your
data to advertisers but expressvpn
doesn't do this they develop
a technology trusted server that makes
their VPN servers incapable of storing
any data at all
number two
now uses lightway a new VPN protocol
they engineered to make user speeds
faster than ever
sometimes vpns are slow and slow your
connection but with expressvpn it's
always blazing fast and lets me stream
videos in HD quality with zero buffering
zero
the last thing that really sets
expressvpn apart is just how easy it is
to use you don't need any Tech skills to
get it set up just fire up the app
tap one button to connect and that's it
even your grandparents could do it I'll
prove them wrong
but maybe your parents could be your
grandparents could you know that my
grandparents are dead okay the Stumpy
incentive here
they've lit they can't they're dead what
are they gonna do right yeah
not possible and
it's not just me saying the CNet
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn the
number one VPN in the world
I love expressvpn it's great for getting
content in other countries Netflix Japan
rules you connect me via the VPN you get
there
say you're from Japan all of the
miyazaki's library
is on Japan Netflix I mean come on
pays for itself
also gives your data private what more
do you want so protect yourself with the
VPN that I use and Trust use my link
expressvpn.com H3 today and get an extra
three months free oh miss you on a
one-year package that's expressvpn.com
H3 visit
expressvpn.com H3 to learn more thank
you
[Music]
yes
all right
we had talked previously about
one of my favorite new tick tock
accounts
uh our boy shirtless Eddie was he was he
really on Parks and Rec
oh my God
Teddy
yeah
why was he wearing a shirt
what are you doing why are you wearing a
shirt shirt on Eddie
so he's a working actor he's in Sag yeah
uh maybe wait what are we gonna ask but
here he is just to jog some y'all's
memory shirtless Eddie is a he's a
committed
to the role
and he is just awesome Eddie what are
you doing outside of 7-Eleven with your
shirt off put your shirt back on before
you go inside yeah I'm gonna go in here
with my shirt off because I was going to
sound level with my shirt off
[Music]
hey Eddie what are you doing in a
7-Eleven with your shirt off put your
shirt back on
Eddie what are you doing with this shirt
episode of 7-Eleven put your shirt back
on Eddie I'm here in the 7-Eleven with
my shirt off I feel great I lost weight
[Music]
the sweetest guy like in talking to him
super nice
I have so many questions just about hey
Eddie what are you doing with your shirt
off put your shirt back up
[Music]
what are you doing here
you really have to ask him Eddie
the man's struggling let him go oh
I feel great
all right let's talk to Eddie you guys
know him all right you know him you'll
love him here he comes the man let's get
him on the phone shirtless Eddie
the legend or Eddie loves C lovesies
loves these oh and there he is shirtless
as ever shirtless as the day he was born
shirtless Eddie
they are eagerly trying to get the audio
to work
hello how are you doing yes hey nice to
see you Shameless who's that sitting
with you
cam
hi Eddie this is my friend Austin from
Boston hi guys he's with me today
showing you he really is a big fan of
the A3 podcast thanks nice to meet you
Austin thanks for helping Eddie out yeah
yeah
hey Eddie how come how come you won't
answer Cam's DMs oh you know why because
I got so many people when I got that 2.2
million viral that I couldn't even uh
respond to all of them and you just got
lost in the shuffle I see it these big
leagues cam you can't expect him to
answer
yeah I'm a big fan I gotta say it's it's
an honor to meet you honor to meet you
too too you're great thank you guys well
I'm glad you made the time
to come talk to us
so shirtless Eddie I want to ask you
what where is the concept for this is
this really who you are or is this a
character you're playing it's kind of a
character I play you know I was in Fight
Club the movie and I was right next to
meatloaf and I got to be shirtless for
the fight club scene that's the AFI Film
Festival top 100 yeah and I also was in
Jack's back red reign with uh James
Spader from blacklisted but basically
you know uh this idea came on my
birthday January 17th was my birthday of
this year and it's I was in a CVS just
checking my lottery tickets and a lady
said Ed why are you shirtless because I
wanted to show that I was on a lottery
machine so I got the idea from her she
goes Ed put your shirt back on and then
that's all that started you what were
you trying to do you approved you did
you go into the CVS shirtless no I
didn't go into the CVS shirtless but
then I thought of the idea because you
know I thought maybe it would be fun to
be in a store with my shirt off I kind
of just came to me you know the idea
right
so is it comedy or is it like a suspense
what would we going for mystery thriller
comedy yeah a little shock value just to
get people to maybe realize that we
should all be free and just you know be
ourselves and just try to get more uh
fun in life you know because life is so
fun anyway with the PTSD from the
pandemic I thought people might need a
fun time it's escapism yeah it is very
nice the content is very nice it's very
good are you a nudist do you do you are
you uh into the nude form
absolutely not you know and I always
like to have my shirt on but uh recently
I lost 30 pounds and so I thought I'd
show it before that's how it started too
I wanted to show before and after of how
I looked and how my body's shrinking
with the before and after and my Chichi
area would get flatter and maybe my
belly would get flattery area
well just you know these were not like
that I was thin my whole life until I
was about 35 and I gained a lot of like
Chichi fat uh recently when I ate a lot
of food there are three restaurants here
in Burbank lancers and like Coral Diner
and like you know tally Rand and I was
overeating a little bit on uh all their
Foods because I really like the three
restaurants they had here and so I ate a
lot of breakfast in the morning you know
a lot of cheesy breakfasts and that came
in a lot of weight you know until yeah
that'll sneak up on you but I'm glad
you're losing weight so you're so how do
you shoot these videos let's say you go
you know they say you go into Walmart
there's a different person in every
video are you just going up to strangers
and giving them your phone and saying
hey ask me why am I in here without my
shirt
yes pretty much that's you've got me
there you know I A lot of times they
like to join in because they've seen me
on Tick Tock and a lot of them sometimes
wave to me on the street if I'm uh on
the Chandler uh Bikeway here in pathway
and you know they'll say Eddie we saw
you in your library we saw you on Tick
Tock you had put your shirt back on and
that's awesome that I have fans like
that that's remember me already on tick
tock
have you ever had any interesting
encounters I can I can see some people
may being sensitive and not wanting to
participate in that kind of video
oh yes a lot of times they might say no
no we wouldn't want to partake in
something like that we don't want to
partake and I usually would uh say back
to them you're lost you would have
enjoyed this or something like that like
it's your loss I'm going on the H3
podcast I just did that yesterday this
the two people didn't want to do it and
so I said I'm going on a podcast you're
lost you could have been famous
absolutely they're lost when you ask
them are you shirtless or are you
wearing a shirt
well usually I'm wearing a shirt okay
because I don't want to shock them too
much to begin right right
yeah where's your favorite place to be
shirtless do you have uh where's the
spot for that yeah it's usually Walmart
because you know a lot of people in
Walmart are kind of the wall martians
and so they're funny anyway and they
have got character looks and I kind of
look around I I got in trouble at Costco
I have to say the other day because I
was in Costco and I was I had my shirt
off and uh that's one of the ones that
first went viral and so uh what happened
was I was in an aisle in one of my I
threw my shirt and my sweater you know I
threw it took through it off so that it
would come off real fast so I could do
the video quick and get out of there and
then what happened was it got it got
stuck inside somewhere and I couldn't
find it and I couldn't get to it and so
I was stuck there with my shirt off the
whole time and then what happened was I
got so embarrassing because of the fact
that you know I can't find my shirt and
some employees spotted me and then he
started telling all management and
security there that I had my shirt off
and Costco came in your people with
their shirt off it's not part of their
protocol
sure yeah I can see I can see that you
would stand out did you ever get your
shirt back or did they just kick you out
shirtless at all yeah I had to get some
of the Costco employees to come help me
retrieve the shirt and sweater that I
had thrown some over the counter did
they ask you why did you do that yeah
they go they knew that what the jig was
up because I first told them that I I
had just uh uh my uh you know I had must
have uh lost it somewhere I lost my
shirt I didn't tell them why and then
they realized that I was making a video
and so they kind of got flabbergasted
about that oh man and they kind of outed
me by saying oh yeah you you really uh
didn't just misplace your shirt or it
didn't come off uh there was other it
just came off I don't see that as very
plausible
yeah yeah so um do you believe in this
no shirt no shoes no service do you
believe that that should be outlawed
what's your opinion on that policy
oh definitely it should not be I think
people in California are just too
uptight right now and you know we're not
in New York City or you know it's not
business all business it should be laid
back and I guess
Beach you know Beach lifestyle Bohemian
and I kind of used to live in uh like uh
over you know and uh I think that they
should just have like an attitude that
you know it is California so you know
Surf's Up or you know just try to let
people Let It All Hang Out Hang Ten and
1970s you know time when everything was
more laid back I mean men used to wear
shirts with their collars completely off
I think you know like I remember seeing
some of the fox broadcasters who've been
on there for 40 years on the Fox channel
11 news and they were from like the
1970s Los Angeles news and and they show
pictures of themselves where they just
had to open like button-down shirts and
they'd go to parties with their shirts
completely
[Music]
well obviously our internet didn't go
down because we're still talking to
Eddie uh one sec Eddie bear with us yeah
from Boston is here with us say hi
awesome
shout out to his account he just started
three weeks on Tick Tock so give him any
love if you can Austin from Boston tell
him about how much you've been a fan of
the History podcast for a long time oh
yeah I love I love uh I love uh
everything going back years I used to
watch Ethan and Ela uh on on the old
podcast and yeah it's great thank you
man how how are you guys how do you guys
know each other
so I just met uh Eddie while we were out
walking he has this path on Chandler
Boulevard that he walks sometimes and my
girlfriend and I just ran into him did a
video with him talked with him for a
little bit and uh he had told me that he
was trying to get in touch with you guys
and was having some difficulty dming uh
Zach so you can figure that out and uh
and now he's here
new friends all the friends we made
along the way yeah Fair hey Austin can
we get you to take your shirt off in
solidarity with Eddie yeah do that
but I'll do it I'll do it yeah Ethan has
to do it too okay then
you're let's do it oh wow
I'm here in the podcast with my shirt
off
right now I just like being here without
my shirt
hey Eddie you're so hairless is that
natural or do you do you oh you know
that's a good question Ethan I uh I used
to know to uh I shaved my chest one time
for a part or something I think I was on
Star Trek and I had to be a Romulan
where I shaved my eyebrows and chests
yeah I was in Star Trek as a Romulan and
they shaved my eyebrows one time and I
never they never grew back and so that's
why what happened you know I think I
shaved my chest a couple of times for
like Hunt for Red October as a sailor or
I was in Chevy Chase's National
Lampoon's Christmas Vacation as you know
in a Christmas vacation movie and I had
to shave myself my whole body you know
for some scene or something and it just
never grew back oh that's kind of great
so most people say the opposite right
you shave it it comes back uh more heavy
but I'm actually jealous of the kind of
that clean beautiful skin look you have
there very nice very nice Austin how
does it look in person does it look as
good in person it's very smooth
yeah come on don't be shy now
it's he's he's got you know
you know a baby so it's very beautiful
it does have very nice skin no no wonder
he doesn't want to show it out he wants
to show it off all the time oh yeah
thanks
but you look good Austin you don't need
to be embarrassed you're definitely way
fitter than I am do you exercise you
exercise I need to get in the Sun a
little bit I'm a little bit uh pale so
it's my Irish skin that's showing
through here that's okay your your chest
hair pattern is interesting do you shave
that or because it's like so specific
yeah no I just can't uh I can't really
grow chest hair so it's it's been uh
it's a struggle yeah it looks good you
look good bro
shirtless man you're in good shape yeah
thank you do you agree Eddie I agree
yeah it's the first time I've seen this
chest we were gonna do a video today
where I was gonna dare him to take his
shirt off so thank you for doing that
yeah this made the Miami break the ice a
little bit yeah
I've never seen you with your shirt off
so that's awesome yeah of course yeah
thank you for doing that Austin are you
feeling comfortable or there or are you
planning an Escape Route I think I'm
okay now but uh I I do have someone on
speed dial in case something yeah yeah
yeah someone knows where you are right
now from his hometown his mom is
watching the podcast right now yeah my
mom's watching hi Mom
love that
all right we're taking about 25 people
to watch it right now and you got about
37 000 people in here watching that's
right yeah that's right
oh you're getting solicited a little bit
in the chat Austin although you have a
girlfriend you have a significant other
Yeah Austin from Boston as a girl I do
have I am taking it very pretty
lady and Eddie do you have a significant
other I don't I'm still single after all
these years you know I'm still single
but uh you know anyone wants to
proposition me hey I'm here for you let
me ask you this
no I'm just kidding
Mary I am married but I can ask my wife
okay you are my type to be honest thank
you I love you back thank you well Eddie
what are your relationships like I know
you're not you're single but are you
um do you get out there you know what I
mean are you having
um sexual encounters
no you know I I'm not right now because
uh with that pandemic it was I felt like
you know that really uh was a deal
breaker for that because you know I
didn't want to catch any of the pandemic
uh uh you know I have to be always uh
proven positive negative you know for
something negative for any of the movies
and TV shows thanks again I can't kiss
anyone I can't have open mouth kiss I
can't do any of that because I don't
want to get covid-19 you know and I'm
omni-chromed a little triple Val that's
a funny thing you ask I'm 19 times vaxed
you know when they had the the vaccines
and the boosters I kept going to the
CVS's Rite Aid and uh maybe that's where
all this started because I kept going to
The Rite Aids and the CVS's and the
Walgreens to get vaccinated in the
Albertsons and the Vons and they I had
like 20 vaccines you know with the last
year you want any vaccines I have a card
that has like every month I was getting
it every three weeks you know is that
even advised by I know I was a walking
like uh you know guinea pig for it
because uh they'd say yeah you know uh
Eddie you've been vacced nine times we
just can't give you another vaccine
because as I'm seeing on here you but I
kept getting away with it so I kept you
know what's interesting Eddie
I wasn't sure there's people who are
anti-vaxx I've not yet met someone who
is uh who's so opposite we're so
pro-vaccine so how does that work
logistically do you just walk into the
clinics and just say hey I want another
vaccine yeah I can't I walk in there
every two three weeks and say hey I'm uh
I need a vaccine uh do me do me do me
you know yeah and uh they just say yes
because they think that uh you know the
more they juice me up the more I might
you know not not catch it and maybe I am
a walking guinea pig for the government
I don't know yeah that's very important
Eddie yeah I don't know that that that's
F even recommended or or that might even
be dangerous Eddie I know yeah it's all
right after a while you might swell up
or your leg might blow up or you know
you might get some sort of uh I never
had any side effects but it could happen
you never felt a fever or anything from
any of the shots no no side effects at
all there's my dog Bruno she's a little
bit
Eddie when was the last time you were
vaccinated
are just about two weeks ago I was uh
omnicron for the third time
omnicon that is really really
interesting experience yeah and they
keep letting you I would think that they
would say no we can't keep doing this
but they you give them the card or do
you say I'm not or you know what maybe
you say I've not been vaccinated at all
yes or I take the little stickers off
the cards with the dates on them and I
pretend that the card's brand new and it
was done 19 months ago or nine months
ago I'm due for one okay so we're still
okay interesting so we're lying to them
and saying that we haven't been vaxed
exactly
don't question me they just do it
that's incredible
Eddie have you ever had um kovid
no I never got home
viruses
how could you
um you know
makes your heart Detonator whatever we
we're living proof this is this is
actually significant yeah this is
you are of significant medical interests
you're of significant medical interest
uh I think doctors might want to study
you yes yeah I'm I'm willing I tell my
doctor all the time I'm willing to be a
guinea pig for whatever you got yeah
yeah I believe that are you getting
vaccinated any other vaccines uh
frequently or just the covid one no I
got the flu vaccine and the uh this fact
I mean that vaccine everything they've
got and you how frequently do you do
that yeah how many flu shots yeah no I
don't even have sex but I I just do it
anyway you know like to have a oh yeah
also like other what other vaccines you
name them polio rabies
14 times
the smallpox ones 14 times everything so
you would you say that you enjoy getting
um vaccinated maybe you know I want us I
guess uh just want to make sure that I
uh that the juice really went in I
always ask them hey did that liquid is
is there really liquid in there it is it
did that medicine go in uh does this
really have a I don't believe leave you
are you sure you're going to have that
in there are you sure this medicine is
this the a placebo or is this real
medicine do you ever ask for a second
dose you're like give me another one
while I'm here
yeah so I have actually I said I don't
think that worked maybe we should do
another one they didn't hit right do
they oblige or no
yeah sometimes I think they did one time
because they they said uh that they
broke something or something yeah but I
don't know I think that that did happen
do you think it's possible that they
know you by now and they're just
shooting up with water or something just
to make you go away
could be uh it could be but they're just
doing that interesting
um Austin how many times have you been
vaccinated
uh uh I think four times right I had
well the first one had a booster right
so I had two there and then I think
twice since then it seems like Eddie are
you comfortable being around Austin
who's only been vaccinated four times oh
yeah that's right don't give me anything
Austin I had I had covet I had kova
twice in four months oh that's so those
vaccines don't do I think you gotta
crank up those numbers dude you got to
get up to like 20 25 right right Eddie
do you have a fire Eddie do you have a
goal kind of for how many times you want
to be vaccinated
yeah probably maybe about 40 times in
one year so that that way you know they
really do find that uh you know they
can't uh I can't ever I'd be totally uh
isolated from being able to have the uh
covet you think you're gonna overcome
covet you'll be yeah there's no way I
can never get you is this you by the way
yes that's me oh I'm here in the fight
club wow okay
did you do any scenes or were you just
an extra kind of standing around in this
well I was just an extra but we filmed
it inside of a warehouse and we did have
to take our shirts off during that time
and then the next one I would have been
in more but the next day I was on uh
Bowfinger with Eddie Murphy and uh and
uh yeah and uh what happened was they uh
so I couldn't come back the second day
but I would have had more scenes even
and uh people from all over said they
saw me in it and and just that both
finger was golden time where you get
like 18 hours because Eddie Murphy
wouldn't come out of his trailer and he
I love that you get paid well on the
18-hour day yeah that was like with
Christine Baranski and Eddie Murphy and
Steve Martin and they did a theater
scene at the Rune theater in Westwood
and we were there for three meals and
like oh no until like eight in the
morning the following morning and we got
there earlier in the day like at six in
the morning the first day and so you
know it's like a 23 hour day almost you
know so you get like sixteen hundred
dollars
uh I believe it's 16 hours every hour is
a full day's pay yes that's what he
means by gold golden hour like when
because sometimes on film sets you have
to shoot so long and that's the rule is
that once you hit that extremely long
shift see every hour becomes a full
payday yeah the our man needs to be
[__] yeah yeah you need to look out
yeah so Eddie do you think it's possible
that you're I don't know is there some
kind of
is there some kind of maybe sexual
gratifications and all this or is it all
kind of just platonic and fun
it's all pretty much platonic and fun
but you know I'm not opposed to if if I
did see somebody that really uh caught
my fancy hi my uh there might be some in
there and some people might be doing
that uh uh just so that they get kind of
their sexual gratification out of it you
know it is kind of a time when people
have spring fever right now because you
know it's February and they'd rather it
be like the spring when they are all you
know uh having sex all the time and uh
maybe you know it is a little of both
okay it's a little of both and then do
you think I I just I'm so fascinated by
the frequency of the shots
is there some kind of gratification in
the shot receiving the shot so many
times
oh yes because uh a lot of times
um I want to see I used to do them three
times each you know just to see which
one would actually uh get the most uh
views because a lot of times uh they
don't uh the first one maybe only could
get 50 views or 100 views but if you do
two or three the maybe the second one
and third one will hit the algorithm
there on Tick Tock and so I think what
happened with me is there was this guy
named uh waffler69 and he died recently
because he ate a lot of food from the
dollar store or Dollar General and I
think I 16 of his fans waffler 69 that's
my gut feeling is that I I met that
Niche that Tick Tock had for the all the
waffler 69 people missed him so much and
they probably when I knew him when he
had 500 followers and then you know he
got like 9.2 million followers or
something but then he died died recently
about three months ago four months ago
out of uh he just started feeling like
heart problems and he told his mom I'm
feeling sick take me to the hospital and
he died on the way to the hospital but I
think it was because he ate a lot of
cholesterol foods from the 99 from the
dollars so I got some of his backlash
from all of his fans that uh you know
they felt like they better fill that
void what do you mean backlash are they
mad at you for something Eddie no not
backlash but uh like uh the leftover the
people that maybe you missed him dearly
you didn't have anything to do with that
did you no you know I didn't but I
thought everything he was eating was
disgusting from the dollar store and you
know this is actually a real matter this
is a real story he died of a heart
attack at age 33 waffler
69. and I think uh you know there are
sometimes there are these myths that
they die this guy I had seen this oh no
I've seen his videos
yeah and so I think you know he used to
chime in and uh it's like he would uh
leave comments in some of my posts
sometimes but I used to leave a lot of
comments in his posts and when he became
very famous he stopped commenting as
much but you think he big timed you a
little bit
but maybe I think yeah pretty much but
maybe it's just you know his sort of uh
people maybe uh they kind of knew that
you know now that he's dead they will
maybe come over to my post now so that
could be the reason and then also it
just because maybe Tick Tock also one
time I filmed two uh girls uh about two
years ago or three years ago that were
uh from comic Comic-Con types what do
you call those when they're Japanese
that um cosplay cosplay people girls and
maybe they're uh they thought that was
too provocative so they uh banned that
particular post of mine or they kept
telling me to take it down I see because
of that it was Trump era time when they
were trying to take down to Trump was
trying to take down Tick Tock and maybe
uh though that happened and so it
stalled a lot of my uh growth on Tick
Tock okay so now years later Tick Tock
tried to make it up to me for having so
told me you know maybe that they had uh
some people try to stop that particular
post simply because they were dressed as
in their Comic-Con outfits and they were
they were of age right yeah they were of
age but they looked Young on camera so
people thought they might have been
younger than they were too provocative
hey Eddie
um are you loyal to one brand of vaccine
or do you kind of sleep around so to
speak
uh pretty much loyal to one uh which is
you know uh I do uh just mostly one yeah
I don't really sleep around but because
the Pfizer is different than you know
moderna and I like the name moderna
because it sounds like Madonna So you're
a you're a moderna man yes because I
think maybe Madonna know that one
Madonna made moderna right yeah I like
moderna too if they don't have moderna
would you take a Pfizer
I probably would yeah sure why not right
why not yeah it wouldn't bother me are
you are you a big fan of Madonna
yeah big van and I've been uh All
Through The Years you know and uh
followed her forever and loved all her
concerts and so you know I sing a lot of
Madonna songs and I do a lot of uh uh of
you know enjoy everything about well
she's a fan of this show I don't know if
you know that she's she's in our
audience
terrific yeah well hi Madonna she could
be watching right now and thank you for
all your 40 years and we can't wait for
the celebration tour yeah here's here's
shirtless Eddie at CVS basically he just
keeps going in and out in and out
you know where's get me that moderna
quick
all right Eddie listen
and you're single and ready to mingle
he's out there he's shirtless he's in LA
and he's uh you're looking for love
currently is that right looking for love
in all the wrong places
and so are you basically willing to make
out with somebody at this point are you
still playing it safe
wouldn't say no to making out okay
anytime yeah you are vaccinated that's
right
I'm probably protected so much that I
couldn't get it anyway no yeah probably
not I'm surprised you're still alive
though man to be totally honest with
that many vaccines but you're doing
great
thanks keep it up man give us updates I
want to know how hot how many vaccines
you can get okay I will do that I'll go
right now today and go do a service from
a vaccination
and that would be a cool viral video
although you know I've heard that you're
gonna have to start paying for it soon
it's gonna cost like 30 or something for
us I liked having it free yeah no I
wouldn't like that can I ask you are you
someone that likes getting free things
sure I just uh uh got this free blenders
for five dollars you know for just
shipping and handling so I can mix
things in a blender you know from dick
talk and anything that's free you know I
want to make sure to grab a hold of that
is part of the appeal with the vaccine
you think that it's free and you like
taking advantage of a free offer
I think so you're gonna hit the nail
that's right yeah because the more you
know freebies you know take advantage of
it while you can because you know for
the freebies won't last for long
everything goes uh to that yeah it's all
going to cost soon so free take
advantage of it while you can okay
that's interesting so I see it's kind of
The Frugal thing are you a coupon cutter
do you do coupons and stuff like that no
but I really am not you know just has to
be free to begin with just four years
or buy for buy one get one free or you
know go for uh to make sure that it's uh
50 off or originally right
well Eddie it's been such a pleasure to
talk to you shirtless Eddie is out there
he's on tick tock
he's everywhere it's been a pleasure
here pleasure talking to you too guys
have a wonderful day and nice to talk to
you Austin thank you so much for helping
Eddie out nice to meet you on Tick Tock
and Austin from Boston thank you so much
thank you thank you Eddie we love you
guys
wow
Oh I thought we were going to stare at
each other for a minute oh sorry sorry
that the way you're staring at me is
freaking me out bro
foreign
how are you man
I keep looking over and it's just like
you staring like really intently
importantly right what are you talking
about
I don't know just like maybe the eye
level is different or something that's I
mean
I don't know you feeling all right like
you good
yeah what do you ask I'm fine
um
love Eddie yeah good guy he's a treat
powerful
what a character
vaccinated King dude he is I didn't know
that people were doing that he's going
he's lying
and he's uh
and he's getting as many vaccines as
possible because they're free apparently
I get that did you get your shots
I could just start sucking blood out of
him and injecting it in people it would
probably
vaccinate them just on his blood the
love that he moves the stickers around
like it's a scrapbook on his vaccine
card there
mm-hmm that's so awesome dude
well there it is shirtless Eddie
um
I hope I can still get that collab with
him I'm a big fan I mean you're a shoe
in now right I hope so he still hasn't
respond I'll send him another message
I'll send you his number please yeah
just follow him text him or something
I'll meet him at any Target or Walmart
of his choosing
yeah
I got a pee actually and then we've got
a lot more to talk about including
the Philly DeFranco drama he called me
out
big time actually
gutted me to be totally honest
I thought he was going to be talking
about our our Nexium interview
and it turned out he was just calling me
out for fat shaming him and normally he
seems like he would but yeah and uh I
was just absolutely devastated to be
totally honest
um devastated
oh
you all right cam
yeah so I'm gonna go to the bathroom
we'll talk about Philly D and also lots
of other fun stuff to talk about
including did you guys know there's a
Nick ocado versus Candace Owens drama
going on
this to me is and I struck the hell out
of me this to me is everything as they
say
um so all right I'm gonna go pee real
fast and then we'll we'll get into the
Philly D
uh Deets the Philly Deets all right have
a good night have a good night hahaha
[Music]
so that was a delightful call very very
joyful yeah I'm a big fan of Eddie now
I'm sold yeah
I'm trying to find him in Star Trek
dude what do you when you were searching
for did you get his full name no I was
trying to find his phone yeah I was
trying to find it too and I thought I
did but I can text him
yeah try and get that I really can't
find that though okay a Romulan shot
Zach do you want to um
plug your live show while we have some
time ah yeah uh you know Zach Lewis live
at the Roxy May 13th going like hot
fondue
that's what we're doing hot fondue
very cool sick
you know I know we're gonna get into
this Philly D stuff but I do want to
just say it's a little bit awkward
because I just bought some Philly D
merch on Friday I haven't even got it in
the mail yet so we need to we need to
figure this [__] out
real quick yeah I don't know if Ethan
knows yet I gotta have a good night I
was bringing on him sure Warren today
all right yeah uh any fun weekend plans
we're gonna go see cocaine bear
anybody else hype for cocaine bear
I don't know what it is but I'm down to
go with you guys you haven't seen the
trailer um it's about a bear that does a
bunch of cocaine it's [__] sick oh
yeah I'm in
I'm sold
[__] I'm sick dude
can't wait
anybody in the audience hyped for
cocaine bear
can you do cocaine with the bear or is
it about a bear oh it's a film it's a
film no I know there's no actual bear
doing cocaine it's fake I I know I know
but like
is like a fan interaction thing like can
you do cocaine with a bear
you can go see the movie on cocaine they
won't stop you can you bring a bear I
don't think the bear would be permitted
in the on the grounds you know uh maybe
if you go like an Alaskan theater or
something well there you go you know
shout out to Grizzly Man shout out
Werner Herzog shout out to Timothy
Treadwell that's the most terrible thing
I've ever seen in my entire life I took
a silly goofy photo with Werner Herzog
not too long ago wait what yeah let me
let me get that picture up oh wait you
have Joe made that before yeah he was
doing a screening of uh it's coraldo
Avana Hedgehog yeah and I took a photo
where I was licking his face
when I saw baby Yoda it was the most
beautiful thing I have ever seen in my
entire life I ate a shoe
foreign
[Music]
impression of the
designer from The Incredibles no oh
that's uh that's more of my God you've
gotten fat
and the mold right I started watching
those with Theodore great movies yeah
they're really good my favorite picks
are the first one especially is like
Flawless man
all right we're back have a good night
no no I just got here you can yeah
Zach um
I want to congratulate you by the way on
the audio in that intro was really good
oh thank you
yeah you're welcome thank you I I really
appreciate that
I think there's a little bit of lag on
your mic or something we need to fix
yeah I know Dan like there's someone
with the latency yeah I'm sorry I'm
sorry we're trying to fix it before the
show I'm trying to do some last minute
changes this morning but thank you Ethan
I really do appreciate it now you're the
man you know how I feel about it thank
you I really you're the best in the biz
thank you I really uh that means a lot
we also
I don't do what products you use in your
hair uh Jeff's Barber Shop
really yeah I use Jeff's Barber Shop uh
some of the Pomade and I actually use
native shampoo and conditioner as well
oh my goodness so uh you know it needs
to start paying us I know it's great
Pomade and
um
you know it's good [__] I love it your
hair looks really good today thank you
yeah you're welcome
all right let's first talk about Aiden
Ross showing porn to his audience I
talked about that yesterday I think
we've talked about kick no wait didn't
we talk about on Monday oh we did yeah
okay so then this guy Jake lucky he's
like a
he's like drama alert but without like
being a giant [__] psycho douche yeah
which is actually good it's actually a
really nice service he provides
Aiden Ross got mad at Jake because he
clipped this the the clip of him
watching porn with his fans
and he sent Jake this message
uh keep yourself safe he says to him
which is of course an acronym
[__] as everybody knows means kill
yourself
and I find that pretty uh pretty
interesting he is turning a new Leaf
glad to see he's sending
super nice dude Aiden Ross Idol actually
Jake had a great response this one here
the video yeah yeah keep yourself safe
you're in trouble bro
you know what he punch he punches like
one of those wind-up toys
they're like they fight like this
scary scary stuff yeah
I don't think we should be saying kill
yourself to anybody Aiden in this day
and age I was kind of shocked by that
frankly I was like really
the [__]
go back to jerking off man you're
clearly wound up it's [__] you up
it's not doing you any good you're
watching porn with all your kid fans
presenting death threats
putting Milk porn
go watch some exploding Milk porn for
Christ's sake
um Arab world news friend of the show
has a message for you Abe before your
big fight
welcome with me our iron hero who has
multiple names also has multiple talents
he is
[Applause]
yeah
please clap he says
he is a big part of the H3 family
this family is not only deep ever they
can't they can't see his little picture
full screen
a shredder
your Shredder crying Worsley I think he
wants to go downstairs where's is Lena
here maybe or is she doing stuff uh she
might be doing something I could text
her
mom can you can you see his what picture
and picture Ian yeah also in sports
maybe you represent us in the Creator
Clash on April 15th so this day the HSC
family will not sleep the night because
our heart is will be filled with
excitement and happens by your Victory
insha Allah inshallah
you lost the whole family is still
behind you
supporting you Abdullah things but let's
make this challenge a little a little
bigger before welcome bill was strong
dad
we know that challenges bring excitement
so my dares for abs as you lost you will
also know something you love like it
shave your hair like this what do you
think Abby I think that's a fair
challenge if you lose you gotta shave
your hair
um so something's on the line for the
family yeah I don't know if I'm ready to
commit to that yet
I don't know Arab world news put you on
the spot bro
I'll hit him with the okay what about
the beard what about the beard ah the
beard that maybe even worse you think so
yeah
there's nothing worse than a dude you're
used to seeing with facial hair then
you're like oh my God you're like a chud
yeah when I when I shave I'm like oh my
God I'm like the Virgin from the Virgin
meme yeah I don't think I could ever you
know shave my beard no yeah it's tough
there's some things you just look great
too they shave and they look like
[__] a billion dollars all right you
gotta have like that Casey neistat chin
otherwise that jawline that prehistoric
chip presents something that you can
afford to lose but that you love in your
life
uh I I I'd have to think on it I'd have
to think on it
how about Twilight I'll never watch I'll
never watch Twilight again do you mean
it though
like you're you're lying you'll
definitely watch Twilight
yeah probably so come on bro if you take
this seriously I I I I have to think on
on this what about your pubes would you
shave your pubes
I think he said he already does that my
peeps already shaved you oh then you got
to grow your pubes out and never shave
them okay we could do that yeah okay
yeah I don't think we have any way to
verify that what if you donate your
bongos to the show
oh I can't do that too many memories
Associated that could confirm
the people bro you gotta put something
on the line
your pubes dude I gotta think I don't
know I should think of what it is I'll
have to come back you bring you bring
something good go get 10 vaccines with
Eddie hmm
that I I couldn't I don't recommend
that's really not safe that can't be
safe right to get 40 vaccines no like
that's what I mean maybe Dr aids would
have the answer oh let's get Dr IDs
I want to ask him about the medical
efficacy of getting 40
covet vaccines
also he said he got like 10 of every
other vaccine in the world I love that
person at all he's Juiced up dude he's
Unstoppable man
I mean anti-vaxx people just just say
here's Eddie he's alive
although they might look at Eddie and be
like this see this is what we're talking
about but I don't know the the funniest
part for me about that conversation was
he called his his uh man boobs his
chichis
yeah
what's the origin for the chichi
people were saying he's Latino is that a
Latino thing
I don't know that that was just [__]
hysterical dude yeah the cheat cheese
we love the cheat shoes
all right let's talk about Philly D who
broke my heart
Philly I come before you today
we used to be friends
what happened to us we used to be such
close friends Philly D
and now you say
[Music]
that I fat shamed you things up right
now this on the day of my
of my great interview with
Mark Wahlberg Mark things up right now
Elliot Elliot Mark Elliott all right
let's watch yeah
let's not do stick now Okay so yesterday
on the members
podcast
everyone in chat
and I have to say it's something I'm
really proud of
and I'm kind of disappointed to see that
nobody's talking about it I feel like
it's kind of a relevant story
Hassan covered it thank you a song We
love you for that
and I thought Philly D might cover it
like a good thing like something good
I've done
and I don't complain about Philly D
clickbaiting me
but it's always something bad it's never
something good when's the last time
Philly clickbaited me for something good
to say congratulations Ethan you did a
good thing today [__] things up right
now
you know what I'm saying
uh you know and I I know I do a lot of
bad things but there's no matter you
have to do something gotta be a good
thing in there somewhere right is this
like a De Niro thing
wow it's got to be a good thing
somewhere in there might be your best
one yeah you like the face that's kind
of spot-on yeah
okay
[Music]
how does General talk that's pretty
pretty good pretty good no that's not
good no you like squinting the whole
smart
just do this occasionally no but what's
his accent sound like you
[Music]
um
you you think I'm a funny guy yeah okay
yeah yeah it's there do I make you laugh
can I can you milk me Philip DeFranco
there you go Billy why is it always a
bad thing why can't it be a good thing
you know I'm not your punching bag I'm
your buddy talk like you you really have
to sneeze like I really
really do
why do you put me in your thumbnails
but it's always something bad and now I
sound like Jerry Seinfeld
Philly D what's with the thumbnails
what's with all these thumbnails
all right yeah so anyway
I was super excited I think I took it so
hard because I was expecting some nice
coverage
the original title was you got whiplash
I did yeah the original title was
Ethan Klein has to stop something like
that
he changed it to this has to stop yeah
Ethan Klein please stop please stop
which is still a reference to me this by
the way this has to stop
thank you
so I was you know first
in the title
and in the thumbnail
so he got a juicer off me
but here it is here's what he had to say
about me the situation disappears right
now and I also you know what it is so
beside the point of this story but uh
since he was mentioned I kind of just
want to say this to Ethan Klein uh can
you stop talking about my [__] weight
on your podcast well I personally use
people saying negative things about my
weight or my looks as further motivation
when I'm working out to the point that I
even do like David Goggins as [__]
like like taking the audio of them
calling me fat or whatever language they
use and mixing it with pump up songs for
my that seems pretty extreme I mean I I
actually know I didn't even hear what he
said afterwards because I was so
devastated he has people calling him fat
worked into his workout music
that's that's intense
views and mixing it with pump up songs
for my workouts there are also tons of
people that deal with weight issues and
eating disorders which by the way it's
well documented that I've talked about
myself having an eating disorder that
I've had to really fight to overcome
over the years so when you say on your
podcast to hundreds of thousands and if
not millions of people that I am
permanently doughy that I am a ham
sandwich it's [__] and I think I can
have a genuinely negative impact on
other people that's where I'm Gonna
Leave it I don't want anyone going after
anyone because of things that were said
about me I just think that we should all
try to be better and then
okay so here's what I say
first of all
I do sincerely apologize to Phil
and I will not talk about his body
anymore right
I didn't know that I honestly didn't
know that he says it's well documented
like I'm supposed to know I mean I
listen Philly no offense I like you but
I don't watch your show just because I
don't have time I don't watch anything
the only [__] I watch on YouTube is like
deep Elder Rings lore that's right hell
yeah based so I I didn't I don't know I
don't know that I mean I know you lost
weight I didn't I don't I didn't know
you had an eating disorder or that or
even that it affected you
um that much so I apologize I didn't
know
the part that
rubbed me a little or I guess I was just
like damn why did
like he's doing this really specific
call out like against me for like a body
shaming him
is it a little ironic that when he's
talking about not body shaming people he
shows like this picture of me which
obviously is supposed to ingest and I'm
very comfortable with my physical
appearance and stuff I know what I how I
experience the world is not how everyone
else experienced the world I mean it's
just a it's just a goofy haircut it's
something I I look fat I have total
control over you know what I mean like I
know but why show that it's a little
like
but why is he clapping does he serious
or is he joking I think he's serious no
I I evidently he has a
he has some body image issues that are
very serious and I think it really got
under his skin that you said that so but
uh do you under do you understand the
point like why use this photo of me he's
trying to make a serious point
because it seems to undermine him a
little bit
because I thought we were joking the
whole time we were having Matt what is
that you hear something is that Shredder
might be Shredder again they can't have
him down there they were right in the
middle of doing that oh poor Shredder so
he's just there suffering
he just brought him back up and he
seemed okay for a minute but I guess
he's getting ignored too much he's not
getting it but he's fine he's attention
up here he's fine
where was I
um here's the thing is that
again I don't know Philly D that well I
didn't know that this was affecting him
I didn't know that he has an easing
disorder and stuff but we were having
like this banter about the fight and so
we were going back and forth a lot on on
Twitter apparently he called me a
meatball I don't remember that actually
we couldn't even find it but somehow
everybody has this memory of him calling
me a meatball
foreign
but um he's referencing
it actually really hurt it actually
really hurt my feelings because
the insinuation that like every episode
I'm like riding him for [__] like I'm
talking about Philadelphia's weight and
stuff because I frankly couldn't even
remember
I don't know it just really hurt my
feelings it just was so out of left
field too like oh and Ethan Klein is a
[__] fat shaming bully who needs to
do better
and me and Philly he asked my number he
could have texted me that's the part
that like if he literally he has never
told me this
I see a lot of people saying like oh
Philly D always tells Ethan to stop
talking about his weight and he never
listens he's not he's never done that we
text we're on texting terms
if he texted me and was like Ethan can
you please stop I would have said of
course you know of course uh of course I
will stop
I mean the last time I remember getting
into something like this with him was
like two years ago with Trisha when she
I remember she said I don't remember
what she said but she did something
offensive that he didn't appreciate
understandably
so
I feel like people who don't have the
context are just going to watch this and
be like oh yeah Ethan Klein he's a just
another piece of [__] who's [__] fat
shames Philly D all the time
and it's like damn it's I don't know
it's just so easy to put that [__] on me
and everybody believes it it's just like
I don't know man
he dm'd me during the Trisha thing yeah
but he
he didn't say don't talk about my way I
don't get that
like yeah I talk I've talked to him a
lot in the past two years back and forth
so anyway uh here's what he's
referencing when I said he's doughy
or that he's a ham sandwich just for
context
let's see number three
now and I also
wait
number three
this was the the podcast we did with
idubbz
and we were talking about like who I'm
gonna match up against boxing and so it
was just a little bad to her like I
don't know I I understand that you know
like I the thing that kind of shocked me
too is I'm always I'm super supportive
of affiliate I'm super impressed with
his weight loss and I feel like I'm
always being really nice and supportive
but maybe he doesn't see that maybe he
just sees this so here let me play it to
fighting it means we'll pitch people to
you who would you pair me up against
theoretically probably Philly a d right
but he's taller than me how much taller
he's doughy though he's yeah I don't
think I mean he's lost he's soft a lot
of weight no but he's like permanently
that way yeah you know I I don't know
yeah it's mean okay I thought I didn't I
didn't know it was affected him that
much though mean
again I was uh we were going back and
forth on Twitter about the fight yeah I
mean probably he's just got that soft
doughy oh I wasn't even really trying to
call him fat it was more just about like
I'm the only the same way
just about like the white I don't know
whatever you guys know what I mean we
call that uh in my family a ham sandwich
now I did not even call him a ham
sandwich and by the way I don't even
want to blame Anissa because we're just
and this at least didn't call my ham
sandwich either we're just kind of
shooting the [__]
I don't think anyone called him a ham
sandwich he is a ham sandwich I think he
has a bag yeah okay but the idea was
thrown around rewinding me too so I'd go
for that oh that timing though
that's all that's what was said about uh
was about him you know
and um I guess I just people accuse me
of stuff so so much
and you know a lot of times they're
right I do do things and I'm not good
with boundaries and stuff like that but
I and obviously I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna talk about his weight anymore just
when I first found out I was live
on the member stream and it really just
caught me off guard
here's Ela working in the background of
our members oh and I also live stream as
Philly D
uh destroys my being Lena was in tears
watching this just seeing how you were
so surprised taking in this info and
then ela's just going ham in the
background [__] great okay apparently
this is good
close the trunk close the situation that
disappears right now and I also you know
what it is so beside the point oh by the
way I I opened um kinetic sand because
his video his videos are a little boring
and I wanted to keep people's attentions
fan
I didn't well can we get through this
I I I don't I heavily disagree there it
is see I feel like he presents the news
in the most adequate way fills the man
bro I'm just kidding what the [__]
honestly like are you serious like this
is like I can't [__] joke
I can't joke that his Show's boring I
mean this is like
one push
don't push
the man's been on the internet for 10
years
you know
do you know what I'm saying getting at
just a little crybaby energy
but I respect it I wish she texted me
but I'm not going to talk about it
anymore but here's the video but uh
since he was mentioned I kind of just
want to say this to Ethan Klein uh can
you stop talking about my [__] weight
on your podcast well I personally use
people saying negative things about my
weight or my looks Ethan will you please
stop calling my show boring on your
podcast
I'm very into okay it's maybe that's not
a good analogy sorry everybody as
further motivation when I'm working out
to the point that I even do like David
Goggins as [__] like like taking the
audio of them calling me fat or whatever
language they use and mixing it with
pump up songs for my workouts there are
also tons of people that deal with
weight issues and eating disorders which
by the way it's well documented that
I've talked about myself having an
eating disorder that I've had to really
fight to overcome over the years so when
you say on your podcast to hundreds of
thousands and if not millions of people
that I am permanently doughy that I am a
ham sandwich it's [__] and I think I
can have a genuinely negative impact on
other people I don't want anyone going
he goes he goes it's not about me it's
about all the other fat people you're
hurting with your language okay
Philly's actually coming for me
Philly's actually making us a serious
Philly's being serious really hitting
those crunches pretty good actually yeah
he put in a good idea I'm like fat
shaming him great form
oh my God what
what did I don't I always compliment him
and say
how great it is you what the [__]
when did I say that
I don't know if this whole thing is
worth watching I haven't seen it it's 10
minutes long but you get the idea yeah I
was just devastating I was I was frankly
I was sad because I expected to see
something good covering the story that I
was proud of
and it happened to go so I was like why
are you why are you doing this now you
want to know what my true honest see it
until
no it was my guess 10 days okay maybe
not that long I think he needed a
thumbnail
I'm not saying that he doesn't believe
what he said
but I was in the thumbnail the first
thing in the title was Ethan needs to
stop the man you know he had an Ace in
the Hole for a boring [__] episode
have we considered Philip DeFranco might
be part of Nexium and now he's gone oh
we haven't saw someone post that theory
on Reddit
that is [__] interesting amateur he's
he's doing a psyop
foreign
yeah I mean look at the other headlines
you know amateur Tick Tock investigator
taserized Town nobody's clicking that
Putin is a clown yeah we know
and today's news
it was Ethan Klein needs to stop
[Music]
the feeling of the earthquake the wind's
blowing so hard
it's um it's almost it's hailing in Port
Orange right now really yeah [__] it's
the end of the world yeah
Abe bought his merch on Friday so we are
we're friends of the of the show
AB you're a beautiful bastard
I resent that he called me a bastard all
the time I have relationships
yeah well the bastard you up like I
could
none of this would have ever happened if
you had gone on the hike with him there
I [__] said it I [__] said it it's
all because you wouldn't go on the
[__] hike you guys need to [__]
make up because I've spent a lot of
money this is retaliatory for the hike
yeah
and frankly someone Justified
it was one hike it's just one hike
Philly I didn't I was busy at the time
you want the top golf
yeah I went to Topgolf at like 9 00 p.m
we going on a 9 pm hike somewhere Zach
yeah
that exists I was busy at the time I
didn't have a babysitter you got that
bright ass [__] flashlight you can
bring with you
I was having a medical emergency the
kids weren't feeling well both of them
let's remember that this is the year
of bridge building it's out and while
you're all over one of our oldest
Bridges just collapsed like like the
London Bridge Okay it's down
and maybe I'm not meant to build Bridges
with a two-hour maybe I'm not a build
Bridger
maybe I am just like the [__] Death
Ship from Fifth Element
all I do is feed on hate and negativity
and that's all I'll ever be
when I see a bridge I burn it
what about Jeff Bridges Hayden
it's the last name actually I love Jeff
Bridges yeah
that he's got to change his name
so I don't know I I am I do feel bad I
just you know I am sorry I didn't know
about the whole
I I honestly he says it's well
documented I mean that might be true I I
don't know
but I have problems with my Dad you need
to stop calling me a bastard
it makes me feel worthless oh my God it
makes me feel worthless it's well
documented that I have problems with my
dad you're not a bastard though you know
he's not talking about you I felt
worthless my dad my dad in a sense is a
bastards based on what they told me
yeah but you know he's we love Philly
he's a good guy I don't want I don't
want trouble with Philly and stuff once
I just felt a little personal it just
felt a little personal
it hurt my feelings honestly
well I think it hurt his feelings too
well I immediately texted him and I said
dude why did you do that just DM why
didn't you just text me
well I'm glad you did
and then he's well don't read his
messages yeah exactly
[Music]
um
that's it you want me to stop I'm out
I'm out
have a good night have a good night Phil
oh my God I'm out
I hope I I his weight loss inspires me I
want to do what he did
you know you're on your way you've still
been keeping it up right
yeah like you worked out yesterday I
remember yeah yeah yeah no I've been
I've been keeping up I mean yeah that I
feel like this is the longest stretch
you've ever no I've been good man I've
been good and it in Philly inspired me
he's looks so good and healthy
you know should take a hike with him and
I mean like here we are talking about I
call him a skinny Legend This was just
in October
he says we're skinny Legends after a
skinny Legend hike
I didn't know that it bothered him
we were just having a goofy back and
forth you know here he is hiking dude
looking awesome he says he's looking for
validation I said I'll validate you
anytime
I'm gonna hike with me you [__] face
see I've been [__] in the face and I
resent that
excuse me I don't know you see me eat
that Subway sandwich
[Music]
got [__] in the face
foot long baby
[Music]
get your balls off my face man so I
don't know but yeah
oh I'm being told this is actual that's
his actual face I'm so sorry Ethan
I resent that I have always struggled
with my physical appearance
and I resent I have uh I have issues I
think I'm ugly and it really upsets me
and then that [__] guy said that
about me damn I felt worthless
I felt ugly I felt gay I feel gay right
now
I am black I am Jewish I am a Muslim I
am disabled I feel disabled I am
disabled I realize as I have Tourette's
that I am disabled today I feel uh I
literally am waiting to get a handicap
placard for my car today I feel disabled
you know what I mean
I was bullied because I had red hair
I've been on the internet long enough
now people can say whatever they want
about me and and you've got to just take
it with stride that's my opinion of
course everyone handles things
differently I'm tired I'm sweaty that's
it quartering nailed it
he nailed it
you know at the end of the day today I
feel uh gay
I I feel gay as a result of all this
[__] yeah he's [__] ridiculous
someone says just stop making eating
disorder jokes when have I ever made an
eating disorder joke don't say it
I'm
have I I'm I don't know off the top of
my head but pretty much guaranteed but
that's not it's not like something I'm
doing I'm not like oh man those
everybody talk about everything is my
point it's just like I wouldn't make a
blanket statement okay okay fine it's
possible I have I don't remember but
it's not like a constant theme in my
[__] content yeah that's fair for
those of you guys who found the Vlog to
be offensive I'm sorry you did for those
of you who didn't find it to be
offensive I'm sorry they did yes
exactly so so many people understand me
it's nice to feel understanded
understood
have a good night yeah so anyway
um I wish you the best Philly you look
great and keep it up
and that is all I will say on that
means
something in your eyes again
[Music]
foreign
that's how I feel Philly
did I should I say something else am I
good no yeah just end send it now so in
summary you are sorry but you just wish
he texted you first that's the I mean
that's the nutshell of it yeah
that's understandable that's the Nutty
nitty nutty of it
or told me and told me sooner too
because I I didn't know about that I
would have totally stopped you know
because he's he's a friend I respect him
he's a friend of mine
you know
yes baby
that's just the way it is some things
will never change that's just the way it
is oh yeah
bro there's nothing funny about eating
disorders
I could probably find something if I
looked really hard but I would never
that's my job right to find the funny
things in life if we can't joke about
you know I'll go there
let's not even go there
it's not it's not my repertoire
I got no eating disorder material
okay
now if I had a little tiny music maybe
we could find a little something
hey
[Music]
hey lady I'm keeping my eye on you
okay well anyway that's it I I got no
hate for Philly we're friends I mean I
still like myself respect and that's it
thank you thank you thank you
everyone says he called me a meatball
which is interesting I saw that comment
so many times and we could not find it
anywhere I don't know if it's like a
collective delusion
Mandela yeah a Mandela the meatball
effect just got Mandela
so you and Trump have such a similar
personality that the meatball meatball
Ron meatball Ron right I see how people
that's spilled over
yeah by the way I felt like we might be
hitting kill switch territory I sent the
20 000. yeah
it's happening people and they received
they've confirmed the receipt of the
money uh yes I think I saw that
people are saying he did call me a
meatball where
like
we looked everywhere people are saying I
remember that
well now that you said it on here
somebody will post it to the subreddit
if you know where it is please it always
happens I'm we were just dying I was
just I need to know where this happened
and to be frank I am meatball shaped
you could just cover me in marinara and
take a bite
put some breadcrumbs on me and I'm good
to go
[__] meatball bro
definitely
lots of people are saying they remember
all right let's move on
let's see what else we got we got Philly
we got Eddie okay NECA Cotto versus
Candace Owens this is [__]
interesting Candace Owen is a right-wing
provocateur she's a disgusting human
being probably one of one of the worst
human beings alive
I think that no that's like an easy
title for her one of the worst human
beings alive
I mean she sucks on a scale of like
Saint to
Hitler she's in like the upper echelon
for sure I'm gonna stop dissing the
Nazis because she wore a white lives
matter shirt like
she's up there she's just a right one
just saying there's people that like is
she not hanged up in their basements and
and cut off their fingertips the thing
is she's not like killed or done any
like as far as we know right but she
does ferment like yeah she sucks like
there's shoot I think there was a sh and
I'm I'm I may not be remembering
correctly but I'm pretty sure one of
these shooters was a fan of hers or
referenced hers
uh there was really yeah there was I
remember that about Shapiro
with uh I believe it was the
synagogue shooting in Canada or
something he was like specifically cited
anyways by shooting a synagogue
I'm hazy on the details but I remember
some Association well anyway you can
look but the point is she's disgusting
she's just horrible I really hate her
she has a video called leftist try to
blame me for the Colorado club shooting
that that that no she was a big one he
he I yeah the club shooting when they
went and killed all the gay people
horrific
that she was uh she inspired him I
believe I'm I believe
not a hundred percent yeah in here at
Washington Post Nazi sympathizer pled
guilty oh was just a defacing a
synagogue it wasn't a shooting but they
in the sentencing memo the attorney
said they were radicalized by Fox News
Ben Shapiro and Breitbart no but what's
the the nightclub shooting with candy
candy
so she's kind of the worst person ever I
mean let's just let's let's put her up
there
you know what I mean uh F tier easy
KKK clandest Owen some people say I like
that
clandioins
so
in this case I'm actually gonna ride
hard for Nick I love me and Nick are
dogs
segment about Nick completely unprovoked
on her show
the daily wire she works for Ben Shapiro
we need to we need to reclaim that
acronym they do DW everywhere
we need to reclaim that
yeah that belongs to DW Griffith
DW
one of the least racist men of history
well anyway she made a segment called
gluttonous YouTubers literally dying for
clicks
that's awesome
Candace you don't know what you're
getting yourself into now girl and I
love it about she's met her match
oh she's so hateful she's such a hateful
little piece of crap
therapy and the over therapeutic
environment that we live in without
discussing social media in previous
episodes we have discussed what women
are doing for attention now they're
setting up cameras and crying pretending
to be sick in some videos or just on the
kitchen floor
no looking up about a bad relationship
and crying crying for likes not because
it actually brings them any relief to
cry on social media so I'm just going to
watch Nick's video because he responds
yeah that's the whole thing less
I gotta see the thumbnail though
can you guys send me this
tell me about your encounter with God
let me see I can probably find it
by the way lady your show sucks
you want uh Nick's thumbnail now I want
to show what I want to see the thumbnail
she made about Nick oh gosh I bet you
it's fire
uh it's right here
yeah okay well that's an accurate
representation of him to be fair
yeah like that is
Kind of Perfect forward actually no no
no no that's fair that is what he's like
nice little plug to The Cheesecake
Factory too
good
okay so um Nick posted a mukbang in
response to Candace where he watched her
video while doing a chicken sandwich hot
wing garlic and fries from WingStop love
that
uh Nick's little dance message to
Candace before his reaction
so what is this
it's just him doing a little little
dance beforehand Olivia thought it was
funny so this is a his his initial
message and now he does he he just wears
this uh what do you call that thing
oxygen tank no no I think that's CPAP
oh is that the thing you wear when
you're sleeping to stop okay right yes
there's CPAP machines and bpap machines
gotcha this is just shtick right like
there's no reason to wear this when
you're awake I mean if he has a
situation where he snores when he's
awake I mean how do you snore when
you're awake duck I mean look at the
poor guy
right I mean maybe if you have yeah if
you have sleep apnea maybe sometimes you
just randomly fall asleep it makes a
little bit of nuts
no I'm just saying
I was trying to back up I feel like if
you get in a relaxed State you know yeah
yeah you can totally Flow State yeah
sure I mean all right let me watch let
me watch this admitting acts up violence
by not recognizing my identity
oh my God and this is a medical mystery
as to it's mostly water it's okay so
he's doing his he's doing his thing
making the best of it so here let's see
here it is
here it is he's getting ready to respond
the old candy
she didn't know what the power she was
fighting forcing with here make sure you
you protect your hands and you cover up
you don't want to disturb the peace
covering up for this lady
gluttonous YouTuber is literally for
clicks
I believe to dying
keeping it squeaky clean dude you're
like half naked in most of the video
made shirtless
I'm perfectly healthy number one yes
number two I am not gonna I'm not gonna
mention his weight
as you guys know
as you guys know would be totally out of
pocket for me to mention his weight
he is first and foremost a human being
of course uh and he's entitled to and he
has a he's beautiful he's healthy
and um
he's a human being God damn it
he's more than just his weight
as you could clearly tell from watching
all his videos it's not the main part of
his identity he's so much more
hello we have the Olivia's back our our
tea expert I told her I messaged her to
come up if she could because oh for the
team well she's the she's the Nick
expert yeah that's a good thing she did
the write-up on this whole video so she
she's the most oh I forgot to mention
downstairs we're doing a photo shoot for
Teddy fresh I walked in and Olivia is
slurping on a 23 Arrow Wine smoothie no
yes no it wasn't just me it wasn't just
me you and there were five that were
ordered and how much was it for five
it was 130 dollars
[Music]
[Applause]
what happened to me I will say
was it as good the second time no no it
wasn't Hello Olivia it was a letdown
yeah it was the first one did hit hard
yeah it was finally blended it was good
it was good it wasn't as Blended as well
huh they probably weren't used to five
people ordering it so they didn't know
the proportions what do we do
we don't have the ingredients I do have
a secret though Ela said it was one of
the best smoothies she's ever had oh she
would say that she always goes against
it oh
it was good you know I admit here it is
here's the traitors
having a laugh
dude there's there's literally homeless
people and you guys are drinking 23
dollars it's disgusting I take it all
back capitalism has [__] ruins
Society it's true
[Music]
the decadence this is literally like the
scene with Joker setting the the
mountain of cash on fire
yeah
I mean you're you're right is the thing
is I have I have no argument
how much would you I paid 10 maybe 10
bucks is probably closer to reasonable
which is already expensive yeah right
first smoothie I don't know prices have
gone up a lot though I don't think I
would get it again if I'm being
completely honest if it tasted like that
and it cost
11 I would you go 11. yeah I'd go up to
11. I'd spend 11 on a smoothie that I
really liked
yeah there's still a lot but like if
it's not it's as good as that shitty
smoothie I'm paying by the way we were
saying it was a 20 it's actually 23.
right yeah it's more than 20. they the
20 wasn't cutting the margin yeah I had
to raise the price I am ashamed I'm
ashamed no I'm just I'm just kidding you
no
have a good night it was a delicious
smoothie treat yourself you know what I
mean treat yourself Wednesday
that's true I want to treat myself
so anyway here's nick uh let's do this
degrading me for clicks to your channel
I've never spoken to you I've never made
content about you I never I'm having
deja vu
has this happened before
I swear I've seen this exact video why
would you think that I don't know just
getting flashbacks both you
and here you are writing my name for
clixture you're a political commentary
Channel
what do I have to do with your world
nada
is your channel suffering that much have
you run things out of things
her views are not are definitely
straggling far behind all the others
yeah he he does a quick check at some
point in the video so you're you're
definitely right on the money there
Nick
I'm gonna give up actually I'm thriving
and you can't say otherwise and I'm not
gluttonous I barely eat that much and
there's actually not that much here
today
so that's the first thing so let's just
play actually let me buy this first
because this is my first time
that's so basic looking though just to
criticize the food like it can't be that
good it's fried chicken and bread it
can't be that way you know what it is
like what place you ordered Wingstop
okay like there's no sauce no pit I
guess there is a little pickle here wait
that's his first time having a chicken
sandwich from WingStop
I find that hard to believe
he's lying he's not being honest with us
hi Zach hey how you doing Olivia
I'm good how are you I'm doing good
how's everything you're doing great
catch up after the show it's kind of
yeah sorry I just I wanted to I just had
to make sure he he looked a little sad
for a sec I was making sure he was okay
I really appreciate that thing friends
are here for you oh
God I will actually he makes me want to
eat that [__] though like I want to be a
chicken sandwich here we go
I need me some Popeyes right now
this is actually great how he does this
because Candy's being a little piece of
crap trying to talk [__] on him and he's
like yeah this is content I'm gonna eat
and watch your dumb video
Popeyes is better I'm just gonna tell
the truth because I'm always I'm not a
ranch Nick it needs a little ranch
like
like I know he enjoys food but even for
someone that really loves food that's a
lot of ranch it's like it's like that
Meme where it's like just a shot of
vodka and like she pours in half the
bottle you ever seen that before she has
no idea that's a little bit of ranch
all right I'm sure we'll start the candy
video soon
ah
and I'm sure this the candy video is
going to start at any second
we have some time stamps in the dockets
unless you're enjoying this
I don't know I can't believe this lady
yeah yeah what's up never mind
let's hear what she has to say about me
thank you enough which is not nice
though by the way and I'm so safe
if you go over here
tags never being able to get through a
video pausing me and Nick yeah that's
what I'm saying we should be friends
soul mates I think yeah
I I third that I want to I want Nick out
here I want to mukbang with him
maybe someday but you gotta build the
bridges well this is it we're building
bridges now I'm full we're laying there
yeah yeah what did he call it you named
you Ashley Olivia is that what he calls
you yes I was Ashley and ELO was Hildy
all right he'll do
it's funny
[Music]
drama YouTuber mukbang oh she did shots
what a boomer she put tags on her video
Trisha Paytas she puts Trisha like who's
doing this these tags
we don't tag our video I'm just like so
old school king of gluttony who's
looking for gluttony you're gluttony
they're like gluttony oh I want to watch
this Candace Owen video I want to watch
him researching the sin of glutton yeah
oh um
Chinese person it says that
excuse me Korean
Seafood there's no Seafood in this video
right gluttony that's misleading Candace
Owens
foreign
they like will help you find tags
that's awesome though Nick is really
taking the Dub here our videos do have
some default tags before we get called
out by the way oh it's just like but
it's like HP podcast Ethan Klein it's
not like gluttony fat guy with a
definitely wife yeah but just just to
say it what would it be though that guy
with the ugly wife
um Jewish YouTube
greedy Israeli clown
um [__] [__] dumb annoying YouTuber
so annoying Batman bed Batman bad
yeah
Tate hey Boomer okay gluttony gluttony
shoes this lady we can hardly talk about
therapy and the over therapeutic
environment that we live in without
discussing soldiers this is pretty
beautiful how he I mean she's trying to
lecture and he's like it's a very funny
you know this is Art it is it's a
political statement yeah it is it is I
think
it is very he is very smart he is very
clever with this content
media
being pretending to be sick in some
videos or just opening up about a bad
relationship and is she calling me a
woman
[Music]
how did you fart on command like that
ripped one
oh my God he's good at what he does
why is a video about me premises by
women trying to get attention I'm not oh
actually you don't know I I have a hard
time
the food in his mouth
crying for attention with I don't cry
that's gonna call you out on that what
you know who else does that maybe I open
my mouth but I don't like dude are you
serious come on what like when have I
ever showed you this
or I mean that that one is light that
one's light let me show you you're a
[__] hypocrite shut up keemstar
[__] hypocrite
all right now I'm just going back
cause you all really talking [__] what
do you think I chew I show food when I
chew that's not that's a show it yeah
just the sound
tell me do I do this
dead
no no no I guess not
are you gonna say I do this
no
thank you
come on
it's a Chinese spot if the Chinese are
spying on my tick tick they don't
deserve to be there
I actually don't like it and there's a
lot of lies on tick tick and a lot of
haters so please ban the app do it I
just saw in the news some some other of
Josh hickey Mickey from whatever
Arkansas's Missouri somewhere over there
all right I'm going to go to the time
stamps because
I'm not trying to watch a 45 minute
video
Mr crazy people well you now have
individuals who are quite literally what
a king he's drinking water
I mean let's be real that's that's good
it's probably Sprite
I don't see any bubbles
[Music]
oh my God he's fine he's healthy he
drinks water he's out he always says
it's a it's a water weight
yeah unrelated I just got Rick Rolled so
[__] bad someone said they they found
the meatball clip
[__] got you got me so [__] good
they got jamming I got so excited
thanks for looking though yeah yeah that
just means you're super into it so I
appreciate that find that meatbally have
a good night have a good night
[Laughter]
for clicks I'm not gonna believe that
this is a trend but there are people
that are feeding themselves right we
talked yesterday about the seven
cardinal sins well gluttony is now
taking place for clicks you know what
else does it said Pride
is being an [__] of sin
being an ass will probably falls into
one of the categories
like let's not even bring the sins into
this okay eating a lot is probably the
most harmless sin there is you know what
do we got here indulging I guess I don't
know
why do they gotta make it all
complicated oh different deadly sins
throughout history shut up there's seven
here they are
lust gluttony greed probably greed
y yeah yeah sloth no no wrath yes Envy I
think she is a little envious of Nick's
success which could be she's like wise
yeah why why am I pride or hubris
definitely prideful she's prideful no
questions at least at least four
pride is not a virtue he's also gay
which I know she hates
is very anti
all things uh
lgbtq plus really a month
that's still that's Jordan Peterson is
such a [__] psycho it's awesome I am
talking in particular about people who
have become famous by binge eating in
front of the cameras
so me
is that is this about me first of all
this is not a binge this is a regular
meal so get your facts straight honey
number two I sadly believe him on that
foreign
right one example is a young man named
Nicholas Perry now well he's interesting
because he actually arrived on the scene
because it's his first video on YouTube
talking about how he was a vegan his
whole life and he now disavows veganism
and then that okay
Candace you get you gotta get some new
writers because there's so many wrong
things about this I can't have it I
don't even know where to start number
one that's not my first video number two
in that video I'm not disavowing
veganism in this video I'm eating 5 000
calories of cheese because I worked out
extra hard by cleaning the sugar right
we had a staircase in that apartment and
I almost tripped
there's dust bunnies running all over
the place
so lies lies lies I mean it's not that
big of a deal
but you're a reporter gee who's someone
that's already going after the major
media a Ramen or a stack of pancakes at
IHOP this was back in 2000 yeah go ahead
oh um just anybody talking about Nick in
general I feel like if anybody would be
curious about how we got that name even
in the first place it was because he was
originally vegan the first video wasn't
disavowing veganism no he was vegan for
like a minute online yeah no yeah yeah
for sure because they're 17. and today
he eats in excess of 10 000 calories in
front of the camera in videos that are
in sense when
ten thousands is rookie numbers I would
imagine for Nick
I think there's probably close to 10
right here on this lunch I've never
ripped it except for like 12 or 13 times
eating 10 000 calories
no but I
how many calories you think is on the
table right well he never he never
finishes he doesn't eat at all yeah okay
he's like done challenges before
skinny skinny skinny King for special
rare occasions extra treats I can still
say skinny Legend right just not about
Phil uh I think just yeah it's not not
about Phil okay so Nick is a skinny like
well
I'm I'm going to retract that statement
I don't know
I'll let you know I'm gonna say it about
Nick nobody's gonna [__] stop well
Nick identifies as skinny okay yeah so I
think that you calling Nick a skinny
Legend
he does identify that way okay good I'm
not even being funny those were those
are rare occurrences for me to actually
eat that much
there's not even 10 000 calories in
front of me right here
and you know what I have to eat to
survive and you don't know you don't
know my body you don't know my blood
work you don't know my doctor
so what if I require it what if I have a
malabsorption issue with like a concert
or something I can only imagine
what a blood some people requests it
looks like for him
sir your blood is 100 uh fry
deep fryer oil
we love that for him though what do you
mean YouTube allows this
I'm on YouTube
what did I do that was so wrong did I
hurt anyone no did I Target anybody like
you're doing to me no am I you know
diagnosing strangers on the internet for
clicks wow
for clicks what they do is for clicks
but look at me true look at me
try to write my name and say that I'm
committing on camera what
that's so degrading
especially if you already have in your
head that you think that I had to pray
and now you're gonna put out there oh
yeah he's just gonna I'm so oh yeah he's
so what if I what if that really
triggered me luckily I don't have
bleeping depression
geez man
um
his hairline is very nice he got that
like comic book hairline mm-hmm
he's cut like it's really nice pretty
perfect yeah it's like a perfect like
it almost looks like the McDonald's
arches this man ate so much McDonald's
his hairline turned into an m
hm oh [__]
but that's good it's good hairline yeah
that's good
you know more things so that they
survive
but you haven't even watched in my
videos I never finished the food in my
videos sometimes yes but most the times
no
give it out into the needy and the poor
when I'm done what do you do when you're
done your food you throw it into the
trash most likely I actually have been
feeding the homeless for seven years
with my scraps
it doesn't sound that nice when he says
it like that but I'm sure it's edible
food
yeah yeah
I have some compassion
titled I hate myself as one example and
Goodbye YouTube and life or celebrating
our 700 pound Milestone now of course
when what's wrong with those titles It's
My Life this hers she's so pathetic
though the video she's made is like so
lame it's not even interesting
because they're irrelevant
I mean like oh but I actually care about
you oh you don't get give a crap about
me they're trying to make money off of
me make your own content make your own
content I'm original I make my own
content that's a really good point I
have tremendous respect for people that
because I I mean we do that but not not
that much so I do respect people that
get out there and actually create the
content
absolutely
that's hard to do and it's you're
putting yourself out there so we tip the
scale to Nick I mean hat I mean make
your own content oh no I am your content
because if you were to make a video
about yourself no but watch
so thank you for I like you know I
admire that about you Owens
I admire you about that you're not gonna
sit here and pretend and act that you
give about me
does it matter
I'm not Millions
I understand he does pretty well and
only fans it seems like
like people you know
yes I yeah yeah I'm sorry I cannot unsee
the McDonald's Arch on his forehead now
this man is Chad called it the mccare
line yeah the Miss Caroline for sure
I actually care about you oh I'm so good
you don't give a crap about me they're
trying to make money off of me
but anyway so
um
okay
his estimating earnings is between seven
that can't be right just sign only fans
oh that's it yeah I thought he'd be
making more I mean how do they know that
a lot of money though wait it says his
estimated well it's far from a million
though estimated earnings is somewhere
between seven thousand and seventeen
thousand and just a quick Google search
but
I mean those things yeah very wildly in
accuracy so he doesn't like talking
about the numbers apparently
that's fine this is it's his option
nobody has to discuss that stuff
um
so what happened so is it not worth
watching
um Candy's original video I don't really
think so she had a response video as
well but uh pretty boring boring no
wonder nobody watches her dumb boring
[__]
podcast
it's all dumb that's right this outfit
is giving some kind of energy she's
wearing suspenders
interesting
why she wearing suspenders
yeah I don't know you like it
and she's in a play from the 1920s she's
doing Oklahoma she has a dress rehearsal
after
she's like I'm playing a character from
the turn of the century that hates gay
people and minorities oh wait that's
today oh that's just me
she's cosplaying
you're a political commentary Channel
what do I have to do with your world
nada
is your channel look at what a
talentless hack
[Music]
you read my [__] mind these people
will have no [__] comedic bone in
them they have no Talent they're just
angry that's all they have totally dead
inside I'm angry but at least sometimes
I'm funny
yeah every once in a while
but they just get paid to be angry they
have no Talent
well suffering that much have you run
things out of things to talk about
that you have to talk about me in my
life imitating his hand movements
actually I'm thriving and you can't say
otherwise and I'm not gluttonous I
barely eat that much and there's
actually not that much here today and
she's not even saying truthful things
everything under the sun and a bunch of
calories four candy doesn't realize she
got pulled into the metaverse with these
The Meta reactions
and here I am now I'm joining the fun
at this point we have four videos on
here
I love that hopefully someone will watch
this Nick watch this yeah do a mukbang
to this
profit right how do you know about how
or not at what point are you gonna
comment
if I want to watch Nick ocado go to his
channel
what is she wearing I can't get past it
Chad said it looks like she polished her
shoes she polished his shoes she's like
an old old-timey huh it it's surprising
too because I she's usually pretty well
dressed like she's she's fairly
fashionable and this one is a bit of a
Miss I don't know but like a train
conductor like a newsie
slay Queen breaking news nicocado eats
too much slay Queen she needs a little
cat you just look at someone be like wow
you you might eat a lot of food so
therefore you have this this and this so
becoming depressed in front of the world
he's essentially himself on camera
slowly I don't even understand if people
oh there's so many things happen we
caught him
we caught him everybody
looks like Larry King oh Larry King
there it is there it is
dead right uh yeah just recently shout
out listen just because Larry King's
dead doesn't mean you're ready to make a
move on the on the throne
Larry King coming for Larry King's
throne 2021
you're like Candace squire
nice thank you nice
what's lower than Square Candace peasant
yeah Squires the the bottom Run for the
Esquire so that was a good one
now did you verify if I eat 10 000
calories a day no
did you verify if I have to no did you
verify if I'm crazy no
if he's in front of the camera and look
at him no I joked in front of so much
McDonald's I can't even I'm just kidding
Isis
like I know exactly what's happening she
she's sitting down with no preparation
and she's forcing a reaction yeah
because they she needs to post content
and um this is just horrible I'm I'm so
embarrassed
explain to you if you're not one
yeah
can't believe I'm saying this but she
could take a tip from you pause the
video you gotta add something yeah thank
you she had some Zooms in there the pot
the pause that ain't enough the pause
meta protects me I'm not taking a pause
it really does like when we when we talk
about fair use the amount of pausing and
adding of comment
like when we did it first Matt Haas we
counted the amount of pausing and the
amount of commentary in between
so
I think Nick needs to sue Owen but I
can't even explain to you if you're not
one
yeah quite the rebuttal there making
entirely no sense I don't know if he's
doing that for funsies but asking us if
we verified whether you ate 10 000 plus
calories you just admitted you did you
said you did it for special occasions
whatever that means and we watched you
idiot oh my God this is not enough this
is oh my God we caught you in a lie Nick
you have eaten shut up what are you
talking about those videos of you
actually doing that in one sitting
consuming 10 000 calories you really
need multi-cab for this
I need a side shot for this [__]
no
please did we verify if you're crazy
10 degrees off axis from the original
it's like it's not the same shot it's
because she got the smallest studio
right her show sucks nobody watches it
there's not enough space for a full
house uh
that can be pretty much confirmed if
you're willing to sit in front of a
camera and consume 10 000 calories for
clicks have we verified whether or not
you're depressed why I do think he
genuinely enjoys it so this claim is for
clicks like I would do that
off camera and sometimes I have
but if you're eating that kind of food
day in and day out and you're doing it
because you want to actually you know
what can we get some kinetic sand going
because she is boring
just put something up there for me
yeah thank you
achieve some level of Fame we can
probably assume that at the very least
you are suffering from some sort of
internal sadness you can't be happy
eating like that every single day and
while you may have people that are
cheering you you're still boring who's
even listening you're not even make like
you're not this is so pointless what how
did anyone watch this
he is definitely trolling okay somebody
knows
everyone's like he's doing it for
comedic effect
he's absolutely loving the attention you
gave him
he's having fun with you so she's the
only idiot in the room that doesn't get
it
go more go or these people that have
bizarre fetishes I guess the fetish
would be watching commit suicide slowly
I am going to be a kind individual and
tell you that you need to stop and that
you can get that same sort of attention
from being healthy that's a little
subtle enough is nice you could you
could actually now say change my mind
just like you changed your mind from
being vegan and then you decided that
you were going to go the other way and
indulge yourself you can change your
mind again and say I'm going to be the
greatest person ever and you can make
videos on the treadmill and walking
slowly our building's about to collapse
shaking so much so you can start to run
until you can Sprint right I don't get I
mean just we want to see that journey I
love before and after right you are at
the before and I don't want you to die
people are following you they do want
you to die they're commenting and
encouraging you and pretending even good
at it it's entertaining it's not we'll
get some power washing
I need at least two feeds to make this
watchable
yeah one sec
I have to wait because I can't
[Music]
I'm not in that camp and I walked in
another reason why I comment on this is
because there is yeah
or turn it down I like that a little bit
I like the sound person yeah I agree
that is really satisfying an undertone
in to politics of course what we were
talking about in terms of the psychology
of individuals that are being raised up
online on social media uh what ends up
happening is it informs policies that we
wow right and Hollywood is neces it is
the power washing thing uh what we see
happening on social media people that
are creating and finding startups on
Tick Tock
will eventually institutional politics
and so we have to always comments
something that is cancerous in our
culture
in my earlier video obesity is
[Music]
okay that was good
enough way through
I actually really enjoyed that once we
put on all the yeah yeah it was super
enjoyable ones in my eyes uh once I
couldn't hear her or see her
I was loving it wow that is look at how
good that is that is actually really
something
that is something
I love the kinetic sand the most that's
all I pay attention to
I'm actually I like the kinetic sand but
these are hitting me different I Am with
You Ethan I think my favorite are them
the power washing videos yeah
very sad that is super impressive man
what a machine
turning back time you know
anyway thanks for the video Candace
really hard-hitting stuff there have a
good night have a good night
congratulations Nick on trolling Candace
uh you did good there
as you could see candy I also have my
own shots so like you're not that
impressive
okay guess what
I could say I could say I'm gonna talk
[__] about you daily wire is just a
bunch of bigoted hateful pieces of crap
everybody there sucks and I can do it in
two different camera angles
that show the leftovers which is a great
show by the way
who's that
Matt Walsh oh he's talking about
something else I remember
yeah so Matt Walsh sucked my dick in
this angle too and Candace I can't see
suck my dick to her that's vulgar which
is a great show by the way
and then can you even move it to a total
side profile because that's the ultimate
Flex because Candace shoots hers out of
a out of a broom closet
that's why they can only get that angle
but as you guys can see we have a big
spacious office
where we can get total actual angles
here
yeah we're working it as we speak here
guys crazy angles coming up
[Music]
yes ma'am
Candace is crying right now
[Music]
yes the tears are about to come down
why does Ethan have such great angles
a perfect 90 degrees go ahead
oh yeah
[Music]
[__] you back to the front camera
Candace Owens is a hateful piece of [__]
now I'm over here see I got it too
better angles than you everybody
join the party let's eat some Wingstop
chicken sandwiches
Candace you're a hateful piece of crap
and you're super boring
which is the biggest crime of all let's
be real
boring boring
even your fans don't like you
[Music]
think she tries to hide that she was
buddy buddy with Kanye like right before
he said we gotta stop dissing the Nazis
no that's what well she's happy with
there okay
look at all that motion it can capture
you probably have to sit still
yeah you can't move like this
suck on that daily wire you suck dude
you go you ain't got [__] compared to us
yeah you see all that motion
you'd be you'd be completely out of here
completely out of frame and you're out
of line shame on you
there it is thank you guys have a good
night
there's one more story I want to do we
probably go in for almost three hours
right then I was just typing that to you
so there's this YouTuber who Brent
Riviera or I guess he's like a tick
tocker YouTuber or whatever influencer
he's
you guys probably recognize him
he's pretty popular he's so annoying he
looks like like
such a douche
like I feel like I know this person from
high school and there's just a douche
well he he reminds me of the old school
like I didn't think this like genre
existed anymore but apparently it's
still very popular of these fake prank
like doesn't he remind you of a prank
Invasion or like dudes like that it does
but his his target audience is young
girls so it's like a whole different
Beast are you crazy
yeah he was a Viner another Viner he
also has a sister who's famous they're
like a whole family yeah here they are
and so
well my suspicions were right he is a
douche
so there's this YouTuber he has 25
million subscribers on YouTube what kind
of content does he make curious let's
see he's like a YouTube uh Mr Beast type
wannabe I guess him and the other guy
actually that's involved in this story
he I I he's just a trend writer he's
just doing the Mr Beast Trend right now
yeah you're a dick rider you're a dick
sucker he gets a lot of views though
he's overdoing the soy face a little bit
don't you think like it's a little too
he's transcended into like uh
estrogen phase oh
skip that yeah it's not invented it's
not just the soy it's just straight to
yeah
uh also apparently he clickbaited
kissing his sister
that's what I'm saying it's just Chris
again Mr kissy day here's his what's
your argument this video has 63
863 million uh what's up everyone and
welcome back to my YouTube channel so
you guys love me the Disney Channel you
don't have to be do that
actually he started a company where he
said he wanted to be the Disney Channel
the internet
uh yeah he nailed it as we know all the
people who came out of Disney were super
well adjusted
and kissed their siblings right that's
common
shout out I think I'm my little sister
Lexi and for some reason you guys like
when she gets me back so today I'm gonna
be doing I can't believe what I'm
watching
I can't okay let's keep watching
um
so starting now we are going to be doing
the pause Challenge and this challenge
is going to last all week so it all
starts right now for this entire week
are you ready Lexi yeah I have one for
them right now pause this video and like
it before it starts hey who's ready for
this I am all right here we go Lexi play
hey Lexi pause
it it's all fake obviously I don't even
need to say that who cares it anyway oh
it doesn't flowing no not the cereal oh
no no she's pouring it she's pouring
here okay
okay
about her
do not waste that sweet milk
pause
no it's all food related
you got you good dude
no oh no way anyway whatever it is it's
gone for kids
his newer stuff is let's see Extreme Hot
for extreme cold so you got a budget now
oh my God oh my God
it's kind of crazy just how much he's
copying Mr Beast
I mean he's far from the only one right
yeah he's far from the alone but not
just Mr Beast he's been called out by
small creators for like completely
stealing their ideas like word for word
copying I send a tick tock in the
Discord oh right I think I did see
something about this like title
thumbnail 100 ripoff
you know you've made it with a creator
with over 100 million social media
followers takes inspiration from one of
your videos check it out I've got a
notebook and I'm gonna go to a fancy
restaurant after the food print let's
see if they treat me any differently I
have a notebook and I'm gonna do a fancy
restaurant act like a food critic to see
if they treat me any differently bro if
you're gonna steal from someone at least
change the words my God
[Music]
what is wrong with you dude
I kept it pretty lucky while I tried the
first couple appetizers after taking
some pictures and give it a few minutes
I whipped out the notebooks
by the way this whole concept that
somehow writing in a notebook is gonna
make them take care of food critic is so
stupid
holy [__] dude like the only people who
walk around with with notebooks are food
critics yeah it's like a cartoonish
thing like oh
hmm I'm gonna write the reviews in my
notebook for the New York Times
fourth and I start to notice a big show
the waiters are talking about me right
now the manager comes up to my table
gives me a car with his personal cell
phone number and tells me to give him a
call whenever I need a resume the
manager gave me his business card and
some complimentary dessert I keep
churning out that nuanced analysis while
they bring I had to take note of it am I
just like well so a daily why is it fast
forwarded like that just so that they
probably could fit it all in one video
because because it's boring uh at the
time I think tick tocks were only a
minute long probably that's my guess
[Music]
sounded demonic for a minute it's the
ghost of George Michaels
um I've also seen he steals a bunch of
others like uh title and thumbnails and
stuff too I don't know if you've seen
anything like that I'll check
but anyway
a few weeks ago Rivera Rivera was
confronted by a fellow YouTuber Tyler
oliviera they have such a similar name
they should be buddies
and he's also a big YouTuber he has
three million Subs almost
and um he ran into
Brent
Brent is kind of a douchey name
love all the brands out there but every
uh person I know named Brent is a
[__] dick bag right
so there it is I'm onto something yeah
exactly except every breath is nice
though Brett Brett that's the thing I
was about to say you're just Brett
you're just Brett with extra steps like
just drop the end
foreign
what about bran we love info bran yeah
or just go Bren it's either Brent or
Brett but this Brent okay wait I I want
to retract that Brent's Deli
that's like uh yeah oh Brent rock man
too okay we take it back we love Brent's
so Tyler approached Brent and his
buddies while they were staying in the
Stanley Hotel it's the hotel from The
Shining
and they were shooting a video in the
hallway
door first he walked outside and they
were shooting a video right outside his
room this is totally all unprompted all
kind of
unscripted right paranormal situation
[Music]
who are you people what is your name
friends
last name famous YouTuber and ex-wein
star do you want a date or no this was
completely random that we both happened
to be filming a video here right outside
our two hotel rooms
Drew what are you guys filming uh Hotel
video what is this Chris
is he really trying to act like this is
real like he's just walking around and
people like he's not in on it yep
oh my God that's what makes this so
embarrassing that's what makes this
video kind of magic it's like what
happens when two of these Mr Beast type
creators happen to be in the same is he
a Mr Beast guy yeah he yeah he's he he
does a lot of videos like that
interesting
maybe okay anyways this is weird we
caught everyone off guard apparently
they almost shot our pants so aware that
I was in the middle of a fake YouTube
prank I wanted to see if Brent would
admit it because we all know his videos
are fake and he steals everyone's ideas
oh this this hey that's the dude who
called me ugly
such a small world
so yeah here's where I thought
so aware that I was in the middle of a
fake YouTube prank I wanted to see if
Brent would admit it because we all know
his videos are
fake and he steals this is the dude
Sam
hey H3 take off the maple this is actual
this is actual face I'm so sorry hey
take off the mask you ugly [__]
how dare you bro I'll have you know that
I'm very insecure about my looks got it
okay yeah
good I'm glad we have an understanding
what's wrong Shredder
are you hungry
hold on one sec
Brian
you know when Ethan mentioned Jimmy Lee
potentially making a a joke insensitive
joke about weight I just happened to
look it up on Reddit to see if I found
anything and first result I found is
Jimmy saying hey who let the air out of
your titties what the [__] that is so
mean
that is so [__] mean it's so beyond
holy crap I thought you were gonna take
a little longer so I was just trying to
fill the dead air but yeah who let the
air out your titties that is vile that
is just [__] up
just to a random person on the street no
less yeah that's our boy Jimmy Lee
he's an outlaw for a reason he's wanted
for
sexual harassment
and 40 on the Run yeah he's on the run
it was everyone's ideas I have a
question for you you guys hire these
people
and unsurprisingly they made a
Champion's newest video it's almost like
they know each other you have a question
yeah do your fake your videos no can you
make your videos
all right
have fun guys I don't know what's going
on here clearly Brent didn't find my
question amusing so
to be totally fair he is kind of being a
dick
the main character here like if I was in
that situation I was trying to film a
video this would be really annoying yeah
yeah I understand they're doing it in a
public place in the hallway where it
says room so that's also annoying so we
have two annoying people clashing right
my hotel room and prepared to go on my
tour of the hotel so we go downstairs
only to find oh God from Affair is right
there
[Music]
okay so that that's where he's that's
pretty good yeah you lost right there
that's that is so
old-fashioned douche off right here yeah
like you're so embarrassing bro you're
you're already succeeded you you you're
doing so well you really got to be like
100 sub loser
you're like a [__] Bully from like a
stupid unrealistic High School drama
hey what's up 100 Subs
it's like who are you that's like a
that's like a uh 21st Century High
School bully what's up 100 Subs 100
followers you know so stupid what's up
um it's ridiculous yeah it's a modern
day bully where it's like cast by uh
Timmy what's the name Timothy Shelton
he's the bully yeah he's the bully but
well so it turns out this guy has almost
3 million Subs so he's about to get
exposed with the capital X
about to expose you baby
mm-hmm
hundreds how many Subs do you guys even
have it's kind of embarrassing that you
guys are even here with me right now how
many Subs do you have Dad
uh I don't I don't have any that's how
embarrassing it is I know
I know
[__] you
we get that louder
hey now they're making fun of his gear
do you even have a directional mic you
guys are so stupid speed this wouldn't
even been a video without that bro you
don't even have an omni you're cardioid
gang oh you [__] loser dude what the
[__] I hear them fine by the way so
whatever they're using is good fine
filming our thing you film yours okay
let's not let's not be okay that's
reasonable disrespectful okay well you
know what's funny
he's the one that called him over he's
like have fun with your 100 Subs
and then he's like hey can you please
stop bothering us let's talk to the
iPhone I don't appreciate the disrespect
what disrespect I literally walked out
of my hotel room and nearly had a heart
attack why did you walk up to us like
enter our space I've just paid 40 a
night for the hotel what do you mean we
were normal guests
did she say she's no him
well she said why are you like coming
into our space and he said I paid 400 to
stay at this hotel
well he has a point because he's like
I was just walking down my hallway oh in
that sense yeah but after that I mean it
belongs to be like following them now
right
it's possible what he said is he was
heading back and then saw them it's
possible that's following them in fact
it's probably likely let's be honest he
saw the vibe that I got is like now he
sees that he has a video and he's gonna
follow them around I I completely agree
that's probably what's happening
although I don't know that's not what he
said
all right all right have fun guys I
don't know what's going on here clearly
Brent didn't find my question amusing so
I walked back to my hotel room and
prepared to go on my channel
get that louder so let's try to
let's try to assess this
let's try to see what this guy omitted
right
because he he is he's definitely cut
this up in a favorable way for him so
here he is right there okay so so he's
there filming them
he sees
[Music]
oh wait it wasn't Brent who said it it
was someone else somebody in the that
group yeah
his mouth is not moving
we get that louder
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey buddy what is that up
put that old camera away you a loser is
that thing even in 4k
put your 30 frames per second camera
away
poor Brokey
thing you film yours yeah let's not
let's not be okay that's reasonable
disrespectful okay well you guys I mean
that's a that's a fair request from
Brent
his friends are douchey he just said
let's not be disrespectful I'm talking
to the iPhone app with disrespect I
literally walked out of my hotel room
and nearly had a heart attack why did
you walk up to us like enter our space
I've I've just paid 400 a night for the
hotel what do you mean
do you think you're elevated Beyond an
average human being you've ascended the
human uh wait what are you doing who are
you guys
have fun guys we're not harassing I mean
they might not be normal guests they
might have paid to shoot there
that's actually that would because is
that an employee telling him to leave
them alone looks like it could be or it
could be private security but actually
if they did pay to have a shoot there
yeah which is possible you're right
because I think they're on the Queen
Mary it looks like it and like they were
making a video that's like harassing
like no they're at a hotel yeah there's
a hotel on the Queen Mary and they're in
Colorado they're in Colorado oh okay
never mind oh oh they're probably at the
uh the dining Hotel yeah they're at The
Shining they're at the Stanley Hotel
okay well regardless to shoot there you
likely need permissions well there's two
YouTubers here at the same time it's
clearly a place people are going I don't
know if it's a trendy topic but so
totally doesn't make his videos this is
totally awesome why why are you having
trouble speaking I'm nervous in front of
my Idols what do you mean well you can't
even talk loser
I know the dude who could cure autism
you should talk to him over at Nexium
what do you got tourettes
they've transcended the average human
that's a good observation Dan that may
have not been a douchey comment let me
oh God damn it
this may not be going the direction I
thought it would be
engaging conversation with such a human
dude they were still talking our mice
These are nice mice so anyways we go on
our silly uh tour finish and go back to
our rooms where we run into Brent and
his goons once so his proof that he went
on a tour was three photos
I think there's a chance he's been
following him
conversation with such a human dude they
were still talking to our mice These are
nice mice so anyways we go on our silly
uh tour finish and go is this okay
back to our rooms where we run into
Brent and his goons once again yo oh my
God we're staying on the same floor that
is pretty fun everybody's like oh my God
this guy again anyway I think they are
actually in The Shining which is right
he's the [__] ghost in this case
is it true you kiss your sister Brad
you're gonna get us kicked out you're
that powerful
yes he'll let us stay that was nice so I
start walking to my room grateful for
Brent's Mercy it was him they were all
staring at us and filming us on guess
what an iPhone where are you recording
it this is kind of weird it's so funny
that this is a shiny Hotel
I do get the sneaking suspicion that
this guy omitted a lot though yeah
that this is very selectively edited and
trust me I don't like bread
he looks like a giant douche he put out
a response on Tick Tock oh so I'm
curious I'm actually curious to hear his
response yeah it's number eight okay
great did you guys film your video
you still use iPhones we can't afford
real camera
what an experience I met for rent Rivera
did you guys finish your video no oh
we're not gonna be able to finish it
what do you mean I'm sorry they're gonna
come and get get you guys they're gonna
kick you out what do you mean we paid
375 right I'm sorry I'm not as rich as
you bro this is the third time harassing
us
you recorded me I'm recording you
because you guys are coming up to oh
okay well we walked in we're on the same
place well he's coming now so I mean you
guys are just gonna have influencer wars
this is really painful
one of us has gotta go look how they're
all standing there with their phones out
like [__] lightsabers
oh God one of us
listen it's your move
it's not big enough for the two of us
when I count to three you draw
I believe an individual citizen in this
country has a right to own a nuclear
warhead
behind you what do you mean who is that
guy
[Music]
you're recording
okay this is literally not your personal
space it's a hallway
I mean
yeah I love the thought of other
people's things that hotel just hearing
this out their [__] room and thinking
that it is haunted maybe [__] that is
the spookiest Haunting of all to
influencers yeah you guys are literally
outside
our way to the room roll the clip all
right
all right is that you well you guys have
about like a minute to finish your video
and then you guys are probably gonna be
on your way out of here all right no
right on my knees please spare me
almighty God Brent spare me I've got 375
on this video so the interesting part in
the end
he actually does get kicked out they
literally put it on a thumbnail on
YouTube instead of true stupid [__]
that's not stupid that's on YouTube I
can literally pull up the thumbnail
anyway
[Music]
wait is that him is that his sister what
the hell little sister goes on 100 dates
that I mean it does look like she's
about to add railed by us insane
thumbnail
I like love holy [__] he's kind of right
about that people yeah
watch my sister get railed by a hundred
dudes
and is this here that's crazy
is that her no that's that that can't be
her
bro what the hell
you guys can stand outside we'll stay on
this side easy compromise after getting
verbally bullied by Brent's
ex-girlfriend who said this where's
influencer and bed award goes to oh I'm
gonna say Brent because he lacks
experience security came to us and said
this
um so I suppose a compromise no no I
guess this beauty is on the way so you
haven't called the police I mean this is
unfortunate all right I swear to God
yeah
go ahead everyone in this video [__]
sucks like that's this guy is so [__]
annoying I'm sorry yeah
so let's see Brent's response because
I'm actually curious what he had to say
um
where's my mouse okay here it is
Brandt's Tick Tock Brant
if you've recently saw come on Brant
tell us what really happened a viral
video of two YouTubers arguing in a
hotel hallway well one of those
YouTubers was me things quickly get
taken out of context so here's the full
picture also this isn't me defending the
things that I said but more so giving
you guys my perspective of what happened
that night so right when I was about to
pull a prank on my friends in a hotel
this guy came up to me yelling and
accused me of Faking the prey and I'm
not saying all my pranks are real but
this one was we were just mining earlier
oh he was gonna do a prank
on someone
okay right yeah not saying the ghosts
who cares if it's really you just said
summer it's just who cares yeah I mean
yeah yeah business of filming a video so
this was really frustrating given the
amount of time energy and money we put
into these videos to make great content
for you guys and as the night went on he
continued to approach us with his camera
saying awful things about me my friends
and my sister to try and get a rise out
of me for his video at a certain point
if
to be fair this is just the same scene
here trying to get a rise out of me for
his video at a certain point it bubbled
up so much that I did what he wanted I
stooped down to his level and I said
something that I should not have said
it was him got some saying it was him
okay later on okay so that's good that's
good
so he is a douche as douchey as I feared
later on he came up weird up and started
filming again this time while we were on
a tour his actions toward us and other
guests on the tour cause the hotel staff
not me to call security he was born
several times by the hotel staff to not
only leave us but other guests and hotel
staff alone and after several warnings
the hotel chose to call the police to
get him escorted from the hotel anyway I
am not proud of the way that I reacted
at all nor am I Perfect all I can do is
be real with you guys and admit that I
could have handled it by not saying
anything and just walking away
yeah you said like the douchiest line of
all but yeah I think that guy's a giant
douche too this is just the tip of the
iceberg actually I was looking for this
if you scroll down
um there was an update there was a small
not a small they have a quarter of a
million Subs uh commentary channel that
called him out and then he falls copier
I strike them
and then a bunch of other creators were
calling him out for it this one here no
go further you know you've made it with
a crater
where's this update air strikes so
commentary Channel named dumpy made a
video calling out Brent
Brent copyright strikes his video oh
that's bad you're making better never
wear headphones I feel like everyone
that's the best that's the worst thing
yeah but he's calling me voice critical
and um yeah and a few other people uh
commented on it calling him out has this
just happened uh yeah actually this
usually a 200 subscriber Channel too
250k sorry yeah
that's insta GG yeah that's GG yeah
there's no one to feel bad about here
like they both got the content I feel
like they both made right here on this
drama
and then let's see after being called
out by other creators like most sure Ben
apologized and donated 400 to dumpy
why'd you give him 400 bucks
to odd amount hey man I saw your video
and I let my YouTube rep know to retract
all the copyright requests I also let my
team know not to copyright your vids
moving forward bro every time they go oh
it's my team shut up it was you I
applaud you for grinding and putting in
the work to make a career on YouTube
nice keep it up little buddy here's four
hundred dollars
here's a little taste
should go get yourself a gumball huh go
stay at the Overlook Hotel
it's something a lot of people are
scared to do but you have proven
otherwise
like me listen it's not easy to achieve
this level of success I wish you all the
steps on YouTube in your career bro hope
we can resolve this
and then he actually donated it via
YouTube 400 in the meantime while the
copyright was being attracted here's
something to help
my resolution air strikes
okay Brent
dumpy is a hater I as I was watching his
video literally just hearing it sounds
like someone that would hate on Ethan
and immediately it popped up
well he's far from the only commentary
Channel dumps it's just called h3h3 let
me just watch the first few seconds I
have a time stamp that I think oh no
come on bro
H3 H3 I'll give him credit he does a
good job with the vote the um
how do you say it the focal range so
that he really obscures the fact that
he's in like a closet and his [__]
parents
in his parents room
you know it's more than I could say for
the some of the other dudes who are just
straight up like sitting under hanging
shirts
oh [__] what does dumpy say about me he
said Ethan is a wrinkly testicle that
needs to be eliminated from society wow
okay
over some really riveting footage
is
the worst human alive I don't like this
person this person really sucks it's
crazy how someone can go from being a
respected person in the community that
Everyone likes and admires for making
original great creative con I don't know
what the stolen from food that's still
going on huh I was like what are you
saying 11 months ago
who's been explained
it's weird so many times
the smallest amount of research there's
like a small group of all these
commentations just circle jerk about
like what he stole from Phil defer I
didn't complain about you making
original content he's just like droning
on over footage from a [__] video
game
he seems young though I'm like I don't
want to go too hard on him all right
fair enough it's like the rite of
passage the 17 year old want to be
commentator channels yeah he's the worst
person alive
he should have [__] died in the
Holocaust
I wish Ethan's Grandparents were killed
[__] killed in the Holocaust so we
wouldn't have to see his shitty videos
but good points in his videos as well
from this big nice place you want to be
to then being a washed up wrinkly
testicle a very bitter wrinkly testicle
a wrinkly testicle that needs to be
exterminated from [__] society that's
really not funny yikes all right I mean
listen I'm not gonna hate it I just
think
advice is not to that that's a little
much I'm not it's fine I'm just giving
you like friendly advice like your
guys's moms I'm giving you Brent Riviera
style advice you know
buy yourself something nice kid listen
kid it's not every day that someone
tries to be a YouTuber like me It Ain't
Easy
I got two angles give me a break
Hey kid it ain't easy but uh Somebody's
gotta do it
what baby I was just saying I wonder if
there's a template to make one of these
H3 hate videos online they all start
with I used to be a fan and then proceed
to say some [__] it is definitely a
phenomenon the falling fan phenomenon is
very real but this dude's like 17 How
old could he have been when I made that
like 13 like what are you even talking
about bro
you didn't even you didn't even know how
to do a arithmetic when I posted that
[__] video how do you have opinions
about it 16 is the age of consent if
only one of them would have went the
other way like me they might have got a
job get a job kid
a star killer but now good job
I feel a little bit personal hit with uh
living at the parents with close in my
back oh true it's kind of yikes well
okay fair enough
um yeah but love you're not like racist
or homophobic I feel like that's part of
the you're not trying to do a podcast
where you're like hey guys it's from
love studios
you're not a you're not a [__] love
thank you you like movement dude you're
the man
you're the [__] man bro uh thanks
Doug shout out movement loves a real one
thanks
[Music]
the elderly man I'm kind of into this
the elderly man rant
I first found out about h3h3 Productions
at the end of 2015 early 2016 somewhere
around there and that was around the
point in time where I was first in 10
years ago almost just to the common
whatever Terry Community I was watching
[__] like great lingerie pyrocynical
um leafy is here Drama Oh What a shock
drama alert that I found each that says
it all
as
a child of leafy's legacy
we all stand on the shoulders of leafy
and I hate Ethan I would say you could
just cut this it's literally just go
canaro's video condensed as always it's
so literally even using some of the same
titles it's kind of fun though isn't it
I like this stuff
let me just watch a little more we
just a little bit release us really late
it's late okay okay a little bit more
stage three Productions I was watching
his soflo Antonio videos and I was like
damn dude this 30 year old guy he's
pretty hip he's pretty fresh he's pretty
funny and he's sitting there eight years
old this dude was pretty hip
foreign
what is that
oh sorry I'm I sent in the wrong chat
just give me a quick second
good work keep it up and it stayed that
way for a few months he made good [__] I
can't lie like H3 was a great content
creator this guy was funny bro
appreciate that but now he sucks
[__] and um then he made a video about
leafy oh no my book okay betrayal bro
and also this was like eight years ago
yeah people don't forget that's true
that's funny good luck though dumpy I
you know you're following the formula
and this is like actually happening
right now it will serve you well it will
serve you well dumps oh see he's popping
off right now
he messaged me oh because of that
why was that a picture of me there
wait hold on I think I think it was a
lag from the previous video sometimes
YouTube
shows like a little bit of the previous
Video hours ago and a frenzy because I
had a community guidelines warning my
very first offense because of God damn
it wait I just saw something sorry I
know I saw it too I'm telling you it was
I really hoped it was it was like a lag
from the previous video
your hand and lead to the yeah
it would be you know it'd be nice of you
though if you like posed for a thumbnail
because he's definitely gonna gonna make
a video out of this if you want to help
him out there's so many videos just use
one of the ones of me like
acid like oh yeah here
Ethan Ethan Klein called me out
H3 called me out
he'll never be as fun as funny as leafy
he's this crazy as really clown comedian
no but no but legitimately he looks 16
so I I just don't understand he was six
when he first yeah you were sick Bro no
wonder you're a fan of leafy I get it
the situation does not progress if it
does I will be making an update video
letting you guys know what's going on
that was me
oh yeah yeah
oh good luck bro I really do mean it
um
he's 20. oh yeah
you should know better by now
damn he's been riding for Riviera what
the [__]
how many River Brent Rivera videos has
he made
one two
three
four five
six this is a okay
good for you bro yeah it's kind of
blowing them up like I said critical
made a video about it mutahar and a few
other people oh oh okay well Brent
Rivera and it's trying to delete his
channel
that's a title I would have used
previously definitely anyway shout out
to the king
dumpy
good love dumping
he used to be a fan and we could we'll
always have that yeah smile because this
happened remember Paris as they said in
Casablanca if only you hadn't
stolen that food for fun money and uh
what else filthy Frank if you didn't
stole from filthy Frank and uh bully
that poor old man Jimmy Lee oh yeah his
jokes about that really Jimmy Lee have
we thought about Jimmy Lee's feelings
like so what he told some random girl
that hey who let the air out your
titties that's so funny that that was
like one of the top talking points of
like why Ethan sucks back then knowing
what we like how the Jimmy Lee thing has
played out over the last two years oh
yeah I remember there was lots of
comments about like I was felt so bad
for that poor man
how Giants have changed
yeah but even then me and Jimmy were on
the same term yeah it was never a
problem but it's just funny yeah me and
Jimmy go way back and we've been making
content since I lived in New York right
we're old friends like that
all right so uh that's it thank you guys
for watching we had a lot of fun here
didn't we folks we're good
we talked to Eddie we talked to
shirtless Eddie that
was an Alzheimer conversation we burned
the bridge with um Philly D
ude
I wouldn't say burned no I'm just
kidding we made peace
we love him
he's perfect the way he is
so I can still wear his merch it won't
be weird yeah of course okay he's
perfect the way he is or will ever be or
ever was
yes
he's God basically
he's a perfect being a sphere of perfect
energy
Billy Philly D is like
a sphere of perfect energy light cannot
enter or Escape throw the music yep in
there yep
all right you can kill it
[Music]
thank you